Hello and welcome to our second drink of lecture circuit part two.
Thank you to everyone who wrote in for this episode.
I thought I'd kick us off with a fan mail flurry.
Angela, it was about the scene where Angela Martin goes home to check on her cats and she licks her cat's face.
And you know, Oscar and Kevin watched this all unfold on Angela's cat camera back at the office, you know, on her desktop computer.
Oh, yeah.
Yes.
Well, we talked quite a bit about this scene in our original breakdown.
你好，欢迎收听我们《讲座巡回（下）》的第二杯饮品。感谢每一位为本集写信的朋友。我想先从一波粉丝来信开始。安吉拉，那是关于安吉拉·马丁回家看望她的猫，并舔了猫脸的那一幕。你知道，奥斯卡和凯文在办公室里通过安吉拉的猫咪摄像头目睹了这一切，就在她的台式电脑上。哦，是的。没错。我们在最初的解析中已经详细讨论过这一幕了。
but Anna C from Des Moines, Iowa, wrote in with this question, and I loved it because we did not discuss this.
Anna says, hi, office ladies, I've been waiting to ask this question.
I love the scene where Angela Martin goes home to her cats.
It didn't feel scripted.
Was some of that improvised?
Well, thanks for that question, Anna.
You know, my memory was that the writers had beats of the scene scripted out sort of as a guide.
But once we started, you know, the cats didn't.
但是来自爱荷华州得梅因的安娜·C写信提出了这个问题，我很喜欢，因为我们之前没讨论过。安娜说：“嗨，办公室女士们，我一直等着问这个问题。我很喜欢安吉拉·马丁回家看猫的那一幕。感觉不像是有剧本的。其中一些是即兴发挥的吗？”嗯，谢谢你的提问，安娜。你知道，我的记忆是编剧们把这一幕的节奏写成了剧本，算是作为一种指导。但一旦我们开始，你知道，猫咪们并没有……
quite cooperate. So I remember our director, Ken Koppas, and I sort of, you know, just kind of
finding it on the day. But ultimately, I knew I had to get to a place where I reprimand Ash,
and then I had to be sweet with Princess Lady, and then it all ends with Angela Martin,
licking her face. Okay. So those were the main beats you had to hit. Yes. Well, I went to the
shooting draft script, Angela, and there's not a lot of dialogue scripted for you. It
was mostly just action beats. Here's what it said. Interior Angela's apartment living room.
Angela takes Ash and makes a hissing sound at him. Ash kind of claws at her. Angela, bad ash.
Then in harsh cat language, war, meow, wow, wow. Angela picks up Princess Lady.
完全配合。所以我记得我们的导演肯·卡皮斯和我，你知道，就是在那一天现场发挥。但最终，我知道我必须达到一个地方，就是我要训斥阿什，然后我要对公主女士温柔，最后以安吉拉·马丁舔她的脸结束。好的。所以这就是你需要达到的主要节奏。是的。嗯，我看了拍摄剧本，安吉拉，并没有为你写太多的台词。大部分只是动作节奏。上面是这样写的：内景，安吉拉的公寓客厅。安吉拉抓住阿什，对他发出嘶嘶声。阿什有点抓她。安吉拉：“坏阿什。”然后用刺耳的猫语：“呜，喵，哇，哇。”安吉拉抱起公主女士。
Angela begins petting her and purring and talking to her lovingly in cat language.
Angela then gets down on all fours and pushes with her nose a ball of string over to Princess Lady, purring and making cat sounds the whole time.
Then she nuzzles Princess Lady like they are two cats.
And then later in the script it says you lick her.
Yes, because that leads to the hair ball that I cough up.
But I will tell you, I did get down on all fours and I did push a ball of string with my nose.
What was the cat's reaction? Was the cat like, what? Who is this lady? First of all, there were so many cats, right? And they just were just like, what is she doing? But I did all this business on the ground that didn't make it in. I'm sure Dave Rogers has it somewhere.
Okay, well, we also had a few folks write in about the scene where Michael goes to find Holly's desk at Nashua. Kate M. from Providence, Rhode Island, said,
安吉拉开始抚摸她，发出呼噜声，并用猫语深情地对她说话。然后安吉拉四肢着地，用鼻子把一个毛线球推向公主女士，全程发出呼噜声和猫叫声。然后她像两只猫一样蹭公主女士。后来剧本里写着“你舔她”。是的，因为那导致了我咳出的毛球。但我得告诉你，我确实四肢着地，也确实用鼻子推了毛线球。猫的反应是什么？猫是不是像，“什么？这个女人是谁？”首先，那里有很多猫，对吧？它们只是觉得，“她在干什么？”但我确实在地上做了所有这些动作，但没剪进去。我相信戴夫·罗杰斯肯定有这些素材。好的，嗯，我们还有几位朋友写信询问迈克尔去纳舒厄寻找霍莉办公桌的那一幕。来自罗德岛普罗维登斯的凯特·M说：
Hi office ladies. During the scene where Michael cuts off a sleeve of Holly's cardigan, I was wondering who made the choice to put her cardigan on her chair and why they chose yellow as the color. I felt like it wasn't really part of Holly's usual wardrobe as I never saw her wear bright colors like that. It really stood out to me and I was wondering if it was intentional or just a random cardigan. Thank you. Oh, that's such a good question. Like, I thought so too. Was that just wardrobe picked that color?
Yeah, I was really curious about it because she's right. Holly never wore like bright pastels.
So Kate, Mindy Kaling, you know, wrote this episode and I went to the earliest draft we had of it, the very earliest table draft.
And apparently it was always her intention for the sweater to be yellow. I want to read to you how it was scripted.
Interior, Dunder Mifflin Nashua, Holly's desk. Michael wanders over to a secluded desk. We see
a nameplate that says Holly Flacks. A yellow cardigan hangs on the back of the chair. Michael touches
her cardigan sadly. He picks it up and smells it. Looking around, he picks up a pair of scissors
from Holly's desk and cuts off the sleeve and stuffs it into his pocket. When he puts back the scissors,
“嗨，办公室女士们。在迈克尔剪掉霍莉开衫袖子的那一幕中，我想知道是谁选择把她的开衫放在椅子上，以及为什么选择黄色。我觉得这不像是霍莉平时的着装，因为我从没见过她穿那种亮色。它真的很显眼，我想知道这是故意的还是随便一件开衫。谢谢。”哦，那真是个好问题。我也这么想。那是服装组选的颜色吗？是的，我真的很好奇，因为她说得对。霍莉从不穿那种明亮的柔和色调。所以凯特，敏迪·卡灵（你知道的）写了这一集，我看了我们能找到的最早的草稿，也就是最初的剧本朗读稿。显然，让毛衣变成黄色一直是她的意图。我想读给你听听剧本是怎么写的：内景，邓德·米夫林纳舒厄分公司，霍莉的办公桌。迈克尔漫步走到一张僻静的办公桌前。我们看到一个写着“霍莉·弗拉克斯”的名牌。一把黄色开衫挂在椅背上。迈克尔悲伤地摸了摸她的开衫。他拿起它，闻了闻。环顾四周，他从霍莉的桌子上拿起一把剪刀，剪掉了袖子，塞进了口袋。当他放回剪刀时，
the mouse moves and Holly's computer desktop goes off hibernation. He looks on her computer. He sees
something, a Microsoft document icon that reads, Dear Michael.
He pulls out a little flash drive from his keychain and furtively downloads the document.
That's that whole scene, but it is very specific that it is a yellow cardigan that's hanging on the back of her chair.
Interesting. So it was scripted. It wasn't a choice of set deck or wardrobe or the director or anything. Wow.
Mindy wrote that. And you know what? I was thinking about it, lady, and Mindy does love a pop of color.
Well, and it's bright and it, I feel like.
You know what it is? It's like a romantic comedy cardigan.
鼠标动了，霍莉的电脑桌面退出了休眠状态。他看向她的电脑。他看到了一些东西，一个写着“亲爱的迈克尔”的微软文档图标。他从钥匙扣上拔出一个小闪存盘，偷偷下载了该文档。这就是整个场景，但非常明确的是，挂在她椅背上的是一件黄色开衫。有趣。所以这是剧本里写好的。不是布景、服装或导演的选择。哇。敏迪写的。你知道吗？我在想，女士，敏迪确实喜欢亮色。嗯，而且它很亮，我觉得……你知道是什么吗？这就像一件浪漫喜剧里的开衫。
Yeah.
You know, you can't have like a sad, tan cardigan hanging on the back of that chair.
Yeah, I think you need something that catches your eye.
Mm-hmm.
Well, Lauren B from New Orleans also wrote in about this scene, but Lauren was pointing out something else.
Lauren says, hey, ladies, more of an observation, but I've always wondered about Holly's computer in that episode.
Did anyone else notice that her desktop did not have any type of password?
Michael barely bumps her mouse and then he has access to her entire hard drive.
是啊。你知道，你不能在椅背上挂一件悲伤的棕褐色开衫。是啊，我觉得你需要一些吸引眼球的东西。嗯哼。嗯，来自新奥尔良的劳伦·B也写信提到了这一幕，但劳伦指出了别的东西。劳伦说：“嘿，女士们，更多是一个观察，但我一直对那一集中霍莉的电脑感到好奇。还有人注意到她的桌面没有任何密码吗？迈克尔只是碰了一下鼠标，然后他就进入了她的整个硬盘。”
I noted the folders around the dear Michael letter.
They were titled Invoices, Payroll, and Address Book.
That seems like important stuff that anyone could snoop around in while she was away.
Please discuss. Love the pod.
I love a background catch like that and that is so funny to me.
So true.
Payroll?
Payroll.
“我注意到了‘亲爱的迈克尔’信件周围的文件夹。它们被命名为‘发票’、‘工资单’和‘通讯录’。这看起来是很重要的东西，任何人都能在她离开时翻看。请讨论。喜欢这个播客。”我喜欢这种背景细节的发现，这对我来说太搞笑了。太真实了。工资单？工资单。
Like access to what people get paid is just sitting there on her non-password protected computer.
Address book, too.
Like, you could just figure out where people live.
I don't know.
It's just crazy.
Crazy.
Very good catch.
I liked it.
就像人们的薪水信息就那样放在她那台没有密码保护的电脑上。还有通讯录。就像，你可以直接查到人们住在哪里。我不知道。这太疯狂了。疯狂。非常好的发现。我喜欢。
Yeah.
All right, everyone.
Here's your second drink of Lecture Circuit Part 2.
Thanks so much for writing in.
I'm Jenna Fisher.
And I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on the office together.
And we're best friends.
好的，各位。这是你们的《讲座巡回（下）》的第二杯饮品。非常感谢你们的来信。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you.
Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
We're the office ladies.
Hello, everybody.
Good morning.
Oh, it's morning for us.
Our good evening.
We don't know when you listen.
现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。大家好。早上好。哦，对我们来说是早上。或者晚上好。我们不知道你们什么时候听。
We don't.
Although, I'm always fascinated.
I love it when people share where they listen and when and what they're doing.
I just love it.
A lot of people listen while they do chores.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
I think that's a good time to listen.
我们不知道。虽然，我总是很着迷。我喜欢人们分享他们什么时候听、在哪里听以及在做什么。我就是喜欢。很多人在做家务时听。是啊。嗯哼。我觉得那是听播客的好时间。
I do too.
I had one gal say she sneaks and listens at one.
work. Oh, what does she do? I don't know. I should always do the follow-up question.
Don't know what you do at work, but thanks for listening to us. I hope everything else in your
office is safely going about its business. Yes, I hope you're having a good day at work.
Today is lecture circuit part two. It is season five, episode 17, written by Mindy Kaling and
directed by Ken Kwapis. Here's a summary. Pam and Michael are still on their
speaking tour. Because remember, Michael was asked by David Wallace to tell all the other branches
我也这么觉得。有一位女士说她偷偷在工作时听。哦，她是做什么的？我不知道。我应该总是追问一下。不知道你在工作时做什么，但谢谢你收听我们的节目。我希望你办公室里的其他一切都在安全地进行。是的，希望你在工作中过得愉快。今天是《讲座巡回（下）》。这是第五季第17集，由敏迪·卡灵编剧，肯·卡皮斯执导。这是剧情摘要：帕姆和迈克尔还在进行他们的演讲巡回。因为记住，大卫·华莱士要求迈克尔告诉所有其他分公司
how to be as successful as Scranton. Well, they've decided to take a detour. They're going to add
Nashua to the lecture circuit so that Michael can see Holly and get some closure. And Pam is all
about it. Pam's up for it. Yeah. But guess what? What? Holly's not there. Oh, no. You know who
is there? A.J. Holly's new boyfriend. No.
boyfriend.
Back in Scrant and Jim and Dwight are still trying to do right by Kelly's missed birthday.
And Angela has a very new, expensive cat that she bought with the money from selling her engagement
ring from Andy.
如何像斯克兰顿分公司一样成功。嗯，他们决定绕道而行。他们要在讲座巡回中加入纳舒厄，这样迈克尔就能见到霍莉并做个了结。帕姆对此完全支持。帕姆愿意去。是啊。但你猜怎么着？什么？霍莉不在那儿。哦，不。你知道谁在那儿吗？A.J.，霍莉的新男友。不。男友。回到斯克兰顿，吉姆和德怀特还在努力弥补凯莉错过的生日。而安吉拉有一只非常新、非常昂贵的猫，那是她用卖掉安迪给她的订婚戒指的钱买的。
And she has to keep tabs on it with a whole video system.
Not even just keep tabs.
She's delighted to just watch her cats while she's at work.
That's what she's doing while she's at work.
Yeah, exactly.
Well, fast fact number one, if you listened to last week, then you'll remember that we explained how lecture circuit was originally meant to be a single episode.
But when they got to the editing room, it was just so good.
They decided to turn it into two.
她必须用一套完整的视频系统来监控它。甚至不仅仅是监控。她只是很高兴在工作时看着她的猫。这就是她在工作时做的事情。是啊，没错。嗯，第一个速记事实，如果你听了上周的节目，那么你就会记得我们解释了《讲座巡回》最初打算作为单集播出。但当他们进入剪辑室时，效果太好了。他们决定把它分成两集。
Yeah, Jenna, weren't you so surprised when you started watching this one, even though I knew that information because we talked about that last week.
On the screen, it said previously on the office.
Yes.
And then there was a whole recap.
Never seen that before.
Never.
Not very documentary, is it?
Not very documentary.
是啊，珍娜，当你开始看这一集时，你难道不惊讶吗？尽管我知道那个信息，因为我们上周讨论过。屏幕上写着“前情提要”。是的。然后有一个完整的回顾。以前从没见过。从来没有。不太像纪录片，对吧？不太像纪录片。
Well, they had to add extra stories in order to make it two episodes.
Remember last week they had the story of Andy trying to date Stanley's client.
Well, this week, the extra storyline is all about Angela and her cats.
Oh, yeah.
Angela, I texted with Mindy about this.
You did?
I did.
What did she say?
嗯，他们必须增加额外的故事来凑成两集。记得上周他们有安迪试图约会斯坦利客户的故事吗？嗯，这周，额外的故事情节全是关于安吉拉和她的猫。哦，是的。安吉拉，我为此和敏迪发了短信。你发了？我发了。她说什么？
She said, she thought that on paper that that cat storyline was a little broad and a little silly.
But here was a thing that the writers knew about you, Angela.
What?
And this is something that Jen Salada said.
Remember back in the duel that you do such a great job of grounding comedy and making it work.
And so they could just throw these broader storylines at you and you made them sing.
She said, what a gift.
Let me tell you something.
她说，她认为在纸面上，那个猫的故事有点宽泛，有点傻。但有一件事是编剧们了解你的，安吉拉。什么？这是珍·萨拉达说的。还记得在《决斗》中，你非常出色地将喜剧落地并使其奏效。所以他们可以把这些更宽泛的故事情节扔给你，而你让它们大放异彩。她说，真是天赋。让我告诉你一件事。
I am on cloud nine right now.
I am absolutely giddy.
Mindy and Jen Salada's opinion of my acting and comedic skills mean more to me than any award.
You heard me.
I will take this Mindy and Jen award to my heart.
I'm going to make you a little mini Jen and a little mini, Mindy statue and give them to you.
Is that weird if I have a miniature statue?
Okay, Mindy and Jen, if you hear this, it's because I see.
我现在简直在云端。我绝对是欣喜若狂。敏迪和珍·萨拉达对我表演和喜剧技巧的评价对我来说比任何奖项都重要。你听到了。我会把这个敏迪和珍奖放在心上。我要为你做一个小小的珍雕像和一个小小的敏迪雕像送给你。如果我有一个微型雕像，这很奇怪吗？好的，敏迪和珍，如果你们听到这个，那是因为我非常看重你们的意见。你今天刚赢了一个敏迪奖。哦！而在《决斗》那集，你赢了一个珍奖。谢谢。是啊。我要感谢“坏蛋女性学院”对我的信任。第二个速记事实是地点解析。
so highly regard your opinion.
You just won a Mindy today.
Oh!
And on the duel, you want a Jen.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I'd like to thank the Academy of Badass Women for believing in me.
Fast fact number two is a location breakdown.
让我们讨论一下纳舒厄分公司。我真的希望你会。每个人都很好奇，因为我们没有去纳舒厄。我们在不同的地方拍摄了外景和内景。嗯哼。纳舒厄分公司的外景实际上是范奈斯的TNR干墙公司。哈。是的。
Let's discuss the Nashua branch.
I was really hoping you would.
Everyone's curious, because we did not go to Nashua.
We filmed the exterior and interior scenes at different places.
Mm-hmm.
The exterior of the Nashua branch was actually TNR drywall in Van Eyes.
Huh.
Yep.
然后我们搬到了——听着。哪里？拍摄内景。哪里？M&M造纸公司。一家真正的造纸公司。太神奇了。对吧？
Then we relocated to get this.
Where?
For the interior scenes.
M&M Paper Company.
A real paper company.
That's amazing.
Right?
是啊。我们在周末结束时拍摄了纳舒厄的所有场景。是在周五。我们拍摄的最后一件事是史蒂夫剪掉霍莉毛衣的袖子。哦，那是最后一件事。但那天我们还拍摄了另一件让我觉得很着迷的事情。这里有一点，我不知道，这是电影魔法吗，还是什么。嗯，你告诉我，我再告诉你。好莱坞内幕。是啊，告诉我。我们拍摄了一个背景板。哦，那是非常好莱坞内幕的电影魔法。是的。谢谢。好的。很好。所以背景板是一个镜头，他们可以把它放在未来的谈话头镜头后面，可能发生在
Yeah.
We shot all of the scenes for Nashua at the very end of the week.
week. It was on a Friday. And the very last thing we shot was Steve cutting the sleeve off Holly's
sweater. Oh, that was the last thing. But here's something else that we shot that day that I found
fascinating. Here's a little bit of like, I don't know, is this movie magic, something. Well, you tell me
and I'll tell you. Insidery Hollywood. Yeah, tell me. We shot a background plate. Oh, that's very
insidery Hollywood movie magicie. Yes. Thank you. Okay.
good. So a background plate is a shot that they could put behind a future talking head that might take
纳舒厄。所以它只是一个空的背景。他们可以用绿幕把人叠加在那里。所以如果A.J.或霍莉或纳舒厄分公司的任何人要在未来的剧集中有谈话头镜头，我们就不必再租整个大楼了。他们只需要在绿幕上拍摄，然后加上我们的背景板。这真的很酷。我只用过一次背景板。是我今年拍摄的一部电视剧。我不知道现在能不能说，但我们必须开车穿过洛杉矶，我们在车里，珍娜，在一个装置上，它会移动。
place in Nashua. So it's just like an empty background. And they could superimpose a person there
with a green screen. So if AJ or Holly or anyone from the Nashua branch had a talking head
in a future episode, we wouldn't have to rent this whole building again. They could just shoot
it on a green screen and add our background plate. It is really cool. I've only worked with the
background plate one time.
It's for a TV show I shot this year.
I don't know if I can say it yet, but we had to be driving through Los Angeles,
and we were in a car, Jenna, on a rig, and it would move.
是的。但我们在摄影棚里，周围是这种弯曲的屏幕，显示着洛杉矶的街道。我头晕了。这是你在表演学校里不会想到的事情，那就是你要做一个假的开车场景，有假的街道经过。如果你容易头晕，这可能会让你有点晕。现在，你能看到屏幕上的假街道吗？
Yes.
But we were inside a studio, and then all around us was this sort of like curved screen
of like the streets of Los Angeles.
And I got dizzy.
This is the thing you don't think about in acting school, which is you're going to do a
faky car scene with faky street going by.
and it might make you a little dizzy if you're prone to that.
Now, could you see the fake street on the screen?
不，它环绕着我们。哇。就像，你知道，那些花哨的电影院，屏幕环绕着你？我不知道。他们有那种，对吧？是啊，我想是的。某个地方。类似的东西。
No, it was surrounding us.
Wow.
Like, you know, one of those fancy movie theaters where the screen goes around you?
I don't know.
They have those, don't they?
Yeah, I think so.
Somewhere.
Something like that.
是啊。它环绕着我们。所以我们看向车窗，就会有街道经过。哇。不是街道经过。你知道我的意思。我知道你的意思。我也在摄影棚里做过那样的假开车场景，
Yeah.
It like went around us.
So we would look out the car window and there'd be the street driving by.
Wow.
Not the street driving by.
You know what I mean.
I know what you meant.
I did a faky driving scene like that in a studio as well,
除了那只是一个绿幕，他们后来插入了图像。但我是在一个小东西上，他们让车移动。是啊，是啊，是啊。风扇吹进窗户来模拟运动。是的。是啊，电影魔法。
except it was just a green screen
and they inserted the images later.
But I was on a little thing
where they make the car move.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Fans blowing in through the windows for motion.
Yes.
Yeah, movie magic.
电影魔法。我喜欢做那些事情，因为那是小时候让我着迷的事情。是啊。假的电影魔法。这也太迷人了。抱歉伙计们，在这里完全跑题了。
Movie magic.
I love doing that stuff
because that's some of the stuff
as a kid that was fascinating to me.
Yeah.
The faky movie magic.
It's also like so fascinating.
Sorry guys to go off on a total tangent here.
但看到这么多不同的部门合作完成一个瞬间。我总是觉得这太酷了。是啊。好的，安吉拉，下一个地点解析全看你了。请告诉我们安吉拉的公寓在哪里，这样我们才能在镜头里看到你所有的猫？哦，我会吗？我有一个完整的猫咪摄像头地点解析。
But to see that many different departments
working to pull off one moment.
I always think that's so cool.
Yeah.
All right, Angela, this next location breakdown is all you.
Will you please tell us where was Angela's apartment such that we could see all your cats on camera?
Oh, will I?
I have a whole cat camera location breakdown.
然后稍后，珍娜，我有一个猫咪客串明星解析。哦，我等不及了。你绝对不想错过。好的。所以，伙计们，安吉拉的客厅是建在二号摄影棚的，就在我们的仓库布景里。记得我们去的那个仓库吗？是的，当然。
And then later, Jenna, I have a cat guest star breakdown.
Oh, I can't wait for that.
You will not want to miss it.
All right.
So, you guys, Angela's living room was built on.
Stage two, that was inside our warehouse set.
Remember the warehouse where we go?
Yes, of course.
好的。我们会搭建很多那种临时布景。是啊。给你们一个术语。他们单独拍摄了场景，然后后来他们拿走了所有猫的那一幕，把它烧录进电脑屏幕里。他们还烧录进我桌上的电脑屏幕里，那张我和猫在一起的照片。这有意义吗？有一点。
Okay.
We would build a lot of those swing sets.
Yeah.
A little term for you.
They shot the scenes individually, and then later they took the one scene with all the cats, and they burned that into the computer screen.
They also burned into the computer screen at my desk, the one of me with the cats.
Does that make sense?
A little bit.
所以你在你桌上拍摄场景之前很久就拍了它，因为那“烧录进你的电脑屏幕”是什么意思？我想那是兰迪用的术语。我想它只是意味着上传，对吧？在后期制作中，他们能够把片段拿出来放在我的电脑上，这样凯文和奥斯卡就能真正看到那些。哦，所以他们不必想象他们看到了什么。不，他们真的能看到那个。那太美妙了。还有，当我们都聚集在一起看屏幕上的猫时，你知道，当是梅雷迪思和整个团队时，我们真的在看猫。哦，好的。那太神奇了。所以你们真的只是在我们的仓库布景里。没错。我在仓库里工作了一整天。很多时候当你去
So you filmed it far prior to when you did the scenes at your.
desk because then what is burning it onto your computer screen mean? I think that's the term
Randy used. I think it just means uploading it, right? In post-production, they were able to like take
the clips and put them on my computer so that Kevin and Oscar really watched those. Oh, so they
didn't have to imagine what they were seeing. No, they really got to watch that. How delicious was that.
Also, when we all gathered around to watch the cats on the screen, you know, when it's Meredith
and the whole gang, we're really watching the cats. Oh, okay. That's amazing. So you were really
just over in our warehouse set. That's right. I worked all day in the warehouse. Many times when you went
安吉拉的公寓，甚至几年后当你去奥斯卡的公寓时，那全都在仓库里。哇。我是说内景镜头。是的。第三个速记事实，我们有一个大客串明星警报。我们有。是A.J.，霍莉的男友，由罗布·许贝尔饰演。是啊。现在，罗布是一位非常成功的即兴表演者、演员、编剧、艾美奖提名制片人。他就像一个四重威胁。那是四个。是啊。双重双重威胁？是啊，他是一个双重双重威胁。他出演过140多部电影和电视剧。天哪。他最近在和马洛拉·哈丁一起出演《透明家庭》。那里有一个小小的《办公室》重聚。安吉拉，你认识罗布。我确实认识罗布。我的意思是，我很久以前通过我们的共同朋友瑞秋·哈里斯认识了他，她后来饰演安吉拉·马丁的妹妹。
to Angela's apartment, even years later when you went to Oscar's apartment, that was all in the warehouse.
Wow. The interior shots, I should say. Yes. Fast fact number three, we have a big guest star alert.
We do. It's AJ Holly's boyfriend played by Rob Hubel. Yeah. Now, Rob is a very successful
improviser, actor, writer, Emmy nominated producer. He's like a quadruple threat. That is four.
Yeah. A double double threat? Yeah, he's a double double threat. He's been in over 140 films and
television shows. Good Lord. He was very recently and transparent with Malora Hardin. A little office reunion
there. And Angela, you know Rob. I do know Rob. I mean, I met him a long time ago through our mutual friend,
Rachel Harris, who later plays Angela Martin's sister.
就是那种洛杉矶喜剧俱乐部的小圈子，你知道，在Groundlings和即兴表演之间之类的。罗布非常有趣。和他交谈也很令人愉快，因为对我来说，他就像威尔·法瑞尔一样，走进房间就自带笑点。他很友好。而且他很友好。是啊。所以我知道这一集要来了，我就想，我们得联系罗布。我们需要听听他关于如何来到《办公室》的故事，他将在这一集中为我们回答几个问题。嗯，这就是他如何在《办公室》得到这份工作的。
It's that little like L.A. Comedy Club circle, you know, between the groundlings and improv and stuff.
Rob is very funny. He's also just delightful to talk to because he's just one of these people to me,
kind of like Will Ferrell, who just walks into the room funny.
He's friendly.
And he's friendly. Yeah.
So I knew this episode was coming up and I was like, we got to reach out to Rob.
We need to hear his story about how he came to be on the office and he's going to answer a few questions for us throughout this episode.
Well, here is how he got his job on the office.
嘿伙计们，我是罗布·许贝尔。现在是清晨，所以我的声音有点沙哑。嗯，这些女士会告诉你，有时在好莱坞，你会得到角色，但机会很少。我想伟大的艾莉森·琼斯选角了这部剧，我做过一些艾莉森选角的电影。所以这可能帮助我得到了这个角色。我也可能是因为认识史蒂夫·卡瑞尔才得到这个角色的，在《每日秀》的时候。我在《每日秀》工作过。在我进入喜剧界之前，我在很多节目里做制片人。当史蒂夫·卡瑞尔和斯蒂芬·科尔伯特在那里时，我在《每日秀》工作。事实上，我和南希·沃尔斯共用一个办公室，她是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的妻子，伟大的南希·沃尔斯。所以这一切可能都帮助我得到了这个角色。否则，如果不是那样的话。我可能有一个很棒的试镜，因为我擅长试镜。但我非常幸运也很紧张，因为这部剧太大了，到那时每个人都成了摇滚明星。所以我不想搞砸它。啊，他没有搞砸。不，他没有。嗯，安吉拉，
Hey guys, it's Rob Heuble. It's early in the morning, so my voice is a little crackly. Well, these ladies will tell you that sometimes in Hollywood, you get offered parts, but it's kind of few and far between. And I think the great Allison Jones cast this show, and I had done some movies that Allison had cast. So that may have helped me maybe get offered the part. I also might have been offered the part because I knew,
Steve Carell from the Daily Show. I worked at the Daily Show. Before I got into comedy, I worked as a
producer on a lot of shows. And I worked at the Daily Show when Steve Carell and Stephen Colbert were
there. In fact, I shared an office with Nancy Walls, who is married to Steve Carell, the great
Nancy Walls. And so that all may have helped me get just offered the part. Otherwise, if that
wasn't the case. I probably had a great audition because I'm great at auditioning. But I was very
lucky and nervous because the show was so big and everybody had become these rock stars by that time.
So I didn't want to screw it up. Aw, he did not screw it up. No, he did not. Well, Angela,
我们收到了乔·S的一个粉丝提问。罗布·许贝尔知道他会作为霍莉的男友在剧中担任常驻角色吗？还是他以为那只是一集？他也为此发来了一段音频片段。我想我知道那是一个常驻角色，但我不知道情节是什么，你知道，故事线是什么。但我确实知道那会是新男友，而且我知道史蒂夫·卡瑞尔会在那些场景中给我制造麻烦，你知道。而且我知道那是和艾米·瑞安一起演，我是她的粉丝，因为我刚看完《火线》。她在《火线》里，我想是第二季，那是另一部伟大的剧。有人应该为《火线》做一个播客。
we got a fan question from Joe S. Did Rob Heuble know he would have a recurring role on the show
as Holly's boyfriend? Or did he think that it was just one episode?
And he sent in an audio clip about that too.
I think I knew that it was a recurring part, but I didn't know what the plot was and, you know, what the story arc was.
But I did know that it was going to be the new boyfriend, and I knew that Steve Carell would be giving me a hard time, you know, in those scenes.
And I knew that it was with Amy Ryan, who I was such a fan of because I just finished watching The Wire.
And she was on the Wire, I think season two, which is another great show.
Someone should do a podcast about The Wire.
但艾米·瑞安也是一位非常伟大的演员。所以再次强调，不想搞砸那一个。所以就像安吉拉说的，罗布回答了更多问题。我们稍后会穿插进去。穿插。穿插。但你也应该知道，他和保罗·希尔有一个每周的Twitch节目，是Twitch TV斜杠Friend Zone，每周四太平洋时间下午5点直播。
But Amy Ryan is just such a great actor also.
So again, didn't want to screw that one up.
So like Angela said, Rob answered more questions.
We'll sprinkle them in later.
Sprinkle.
But you should also know that he has a weekly Twitch show with Paul Shear,
which is Twitch TV slash Friend Zone, and it's live every Thursday at 5 Pacific.
再为罗布打个广告，因为我觉得他太搞笑了，他和我的朋友亚伦·海耶斯一起做节目，我曾和她一起拍过一部叫《奥兰多辣妻》的剧。他们的节目叫《医疗警察》。真的很有趣。在Netflix上。它是《儿童医院》的衍生剧。有趣，有趣的人。我想我们应该休息一下，然后去纳舒厄，参加生日派对，舔一些猫。我的意思是，你以为你会说出这样的句子吗？不。今天很独特。嗯，你知道我以为我不会做什么吗？什么？
One more plug for Rob, because I think he's so hilarious, and he does the show with my friend Aaron Hayes that I did a show called Hot Wives of Orlando with.
Their show is called Medical Police Guys. It's really funny. It's on Netflix. It's a spinoff of Children's Hospital.
Funny, funny folks. I think we should take a break and then go to Nashua and a birthday party and lick some cats.
I mean, did you think you'd ever say that in a sentence?
No.
Today is unique.
Well, you know what I didn't think I would do?
What?
谷歌搜索如何舔你的猫。我等不及了。好的。嘿，我是吉尔·施莱辛格。我正在推出一个新节目。它叫《金钱动向》，你的钱将会动起来。我们将帮助你做出更好的财务决策。我们将揭露那些BS。
Google how to lick your cat.
I can't wait for this.
Okay.
Hey there, it's Jill Schlesinger.
I'm launching a new show.
It's called Money Moves, and your money is going to move.
We're going to help you make better financial decisions.
We're going to call out the BS.
你在社交媒体上到处都能找到。我们将为你提供可操作的指导，让你的财务生活更清晰、压力更小。我们将回答你的财务问题，并揭开你财务生活的神秘面纱。在任何你获取播客的地方关注并收听吉尔·施莱辛格的《金钱动向》。我们从厨房开始这一集。凯文正在吃两个冰淇淋零食。他有一个冰棒。你知道那种双棍冰棒。是啊。然后是那种冰淇淋甜筒，上面有巧克力和花生碎之类的东西。是啊，那叫什么来着？某种鼓槌。
You're finding all over social media.
We're going to give you actionable guidance to make your
financial life clearer, less stressful. We're going to answer your financial questions and take the mystery
out of your financial life. Follow and listen to Money Moves with Jill Schlesinger, wherever you get your
podcast. We begin this episode in the kitchen. Kevin's eating two ice cream treats. He has a popsicle.
You know the double stick popsicle. Yep. And then like the ice cream cone with like the
chocolate with the peanut topping thing. Yeah, what's that called again? Some kind of
the drumstick.
就是那个。哦，它是一个鼓槌。鼓槌。是啊。不管怎样，他两个都在吃。但你知道吗？那是因为他没吃午饭。嗯。
That's it.
Oh, it is a drumstick.
Drumstick.
Yeah.
Anyway, he's got both of those going.
But you know what?
It's because he didn't eat his lunch.
Well.
我是说他没吃完午饭。没关系。安吉拉微笑着走进来。很奇怪。容光焕发。太开心了。欣喜若狂。她太开心了，以至于她看着凯文，你知道，
I mean all his lunch.
It doesn't matter.
Angela enters smiling.
It's strange.
Beaming.
So happy.
Giddy.
She's so happy that she looks at Kevin and you know,
正常的安吉拉只会看着他吃那个双棍冰棒和鼓槌，然后对他发火。但她什么也没说。不。事实上，她说：“哦，大家好。哦，冰淇淋。不错，凯文。看起来不错。”
normal Angela would just look at him eating that double stick popsicle and the drumstick
and just go off on him.
But she says nothing.
No.
Actually, she says, oh, hello, everyone.
Oh, ice cream.
Nice, Kevin.
Looks good.
“不错，凯文？”发生了什么？嗯，我告诉你发生了什么。她要宣布她家庭的新成员。那是一只猫，一只稀有特别的猫，一只7000美元的猫。她是低过敏性的。当你试图给她穿衣服时，她不会挣扎。她是第三代展示猫。
Nice, Kevin?
What is happening?
Well, I'll tell you what's happening.
She is going to announce a new addition to her family.
It's a cat, a rare special cat, a $7,000 cat.
She's hypoallergenic.
She doesn't struggle when you try to dress her.
She's a third-generation show cat.
她的父亲出演过《拜见岳父大人》。等等，所以在《拜见岳父大人》里在马桶上撒尿的那只猫和安吉拉的新猫有亲戚关系？那是公主女士的爸爸。哇。我知道。嗯，大家想看这只猫。他们就像，“7000美元的猫？我得看看。”
her father was in Meet the Parents.
Wait, so the cat that pees on the toilet and meet the parents is somehow related to Angela's new cat?
It's Princess Lady's dad.
Wow.
I know.
Well, the gang wants to see this cat.
They're like a $7,000 cat.
I got to see it.
安吉拉说：“我可以比照片做得更好。”哦，她可以。她在家里安装了一个猫咪摄像头。所以她把大家带到她的电脑前，他们看着这些猫在她的客厅里嬉戏。有多少只？我没数。我的意思是，有很多。有很多。
And Angel's like, I can do better than a picture.
Oh, she can.
She has a kitty cam set up at home.
So she takes the whole gang over to her computer and they are watching these cats frolic in her living room.
How many are there?
I didn't count.
I mean, there's lots.
There's lots.
可能有12只。我的意思是，至少有七八只，至少在照片里是这样。谁知道有没有人坐在窗户里？我们不知道。安吉拉，我们收到了很多关于这一幕的信，因为你的角色提到她很烦，她不能休假。她没有剩下的病假了。而且他们不承认猫咪产假。
There's probably 12.
I mean, there were at least seven or eight, at least in the picture.
Who knows if someone was sitting in the window?
We don't know.
Angela, we got a lot of mail about this scene because your character mentions that she's
annoyed, that she can't take any time off.
She doesn't have any sick days left.
And they don't recognize cat maternity.
是啊。而且她不能像那些生人类婴儿的人一样休一年假，这不公平。梅雷迪思同意了，对吧？梅雷迪思说：“是啊，我生第二个孩子就是为了假期。”信件如雪片般飞来。我的意思是，那是一场信件暴风雪。哦，很多人问，“梅雷迪思有几个孩子？”在《联盟》中，德怀特说她有两个孩子。在《受伤》中，迈克尔说她有一个孩子，没有丈夫。在《带女儿上班日》，她带了一个孩子来。但在这里，她说她有第二个孩子。剧本圣经怎么说？我告诉你们，伙计们，剧本圣经只是剧本说什么就是什么。
Yeah.
And it's not fair that she can't take off a year, like those people who have,
human babies. And Meredith agrees, right? Meredith says, yeah, I had my second kid just for the
vacation time. Flurry of mail. I mean, it was a snowstorm of letters. Oh, lots of people are like,
how many children does Meredith have? In Alliance, Dwight says she has two kids. In the injury,
Michael says she has one kid, no husband. And take your daughter to workday, she brings one child in.
But then here, she says she has a second kid. What does the show Bible say?
I'll tell you guys, the show Bible just says whatever the show says.
所以剧本圣经和这些剧集一样混乱。我想我们真的不知道。我想也许我们在记录孩子方面做得不好。我的意思是，参议员的儿子怎么了？哦，是的，我们会讲到的。孩子们在我们的剧里总是消失又出现。我想发生的事情是他们写剧本时并没有先检查剧本圣经。然后那个保管剧本圣经的人就像，“该死，我现在得在剧本圣经里写点东西，这与剧本圣经里已经有的内容相矛盾。”
So the show Bible is as all over the place as these episodes.
I think we don't really know.
I think maybe we didn't do a good job keeping track of the children.
I mean, what happens to the Senator's son?
Oh, yeah, we'll get there.
Children disappear and reappear all the time on our show.
I think what happens is they write the episode and they don't check the show Bible first.
And then the person who keeps the show Bible is like, dang it, I've got to write something in the show Bible now that contradicts what was already in the show Bible.
但是，你知道，他们的工作只是记录发生的事情。我经常收到关于公主女士的问题。人们想知道她为什么要卖掉安迪的订婚戒指。当这一集播出时，评论区里的每个人都真的因为这个评判安吉拉。有一个被删掉的谈话头镜头，她解释了原因。我想我们应该听听。如你所知，我不再处于恋爱关系中了。这里一直压力很大。
But, you know, their job is just to record what happens.
I've gotten questions quite a bit about Princess Lady.
People want to know why would she sell Andy's engagement ring.
Everyone sort of really judged Angela for this on the comment boards back when the episode aired.
There was a deleted talking head where she sort of explained it.
and I think we should hear it.
As you may know, I am no longer in a relationships.
It's been really stressful here.
所以我决定用上帝最完美的创造之一来犒劳自己。一只美丽的新猫。谈论钱很俗气。但她花了7000美元。好的，伙计们，评判安吉拉吧，如果你愿意的话，但她经历了一段艰难的时期，因为她不再处于恋爱关系中了。她的两段关系都结束了，她必须和他们两个一起工作，每天见到他们。她有点被排斥，被踢出了派对策划委员会，她去做了冲动消费来让自己感觉好一点。
So I decided to treat myself to one of God's most perfect creations.
A beautiful new cat.
It's tacky to talk about money.
But she costs $7,000.
Okay, you guys, Judge Angela, if you will,
but she's had a tough time because she's no longer in a relationship.
Both of her relationships have ended, and she has to work with both of them and see them every day.
She's sort of been shunned, kicked off the party planning committee, and she went and made an impulse by to make herself feel better.
这就是我要说的。她本应该把戒指还回去。我知道。我知道。因为她不忠。是的。你知道，戒指是你承诺的象征，是你结婚契约的象征。而且我认为如果拥有戒指的人打破了那个契约，他们应该归还它。
Here's what I'll say.
She should have given the ring back.
I know that.
Because she was unfaithful.
Yes.
You know, the ring is a symbol of your promise, of your contract to be married.
and I think that if the person who has the ring breaks that contract, they should return it.
但我相信礼仪说，如果给戒指的人打破了契约，你可以保留戒指。嗯，安吉拉·马丁要用她的去买一只猫。嗯哼。她打破了礼仪。是的。好的。我的意思是，那是你的角色会做的事。你认为帕姆把戒指还给罗伊了吗？
But I believe that etiquette says that if the person who gave the ring breaks the contract, you get to keep the ring.
Well, Angela Martin's going to use hers to buy a cat.
Mm-hmm.
She broke with the etiquette.
Yes.
Okay.
I mean, that's what your character would do.
Do you think Pam gave Roy the ring back?
我这么认为。对吧？现在，听着，你可能会对安吉拉·马丁表示不满。她的外遇非常明显，但我认为帕姆有精神出轨。你觉得？当然有。所以我只是说。这就是为什么我认为帕姆把戒指还了。嗯，公主女士在这儿，伙计们。是的。嗯，说到今天很兴奋的人，吉姆很高兴给凯莉买了冰淇淋蛋糕。他把它放进冰箱里。他为自己感到骄傲。他做到了。但随后他听到德怀特。对着凯莉大喊大叫。就在她脸上。德怀特这样做。记得他直接对着菲利斯的脸吗？是的。他们在这一幕中笑了很多吗？我不知道敏迪是怎么忍住的。
I do.
Right? Now, listen, you might throw some shade at Angela Martin. Her affair was very out there, but I think Pam had an emotional affair.
You think? Of course she did. So I'm just saying. That's why I think Pam gave the ring back.
Well, Princess Lady is here, folks. Yes. Well, speaking of people who are excited today, Jim is thrilled to have purchased Kelly and ice cream cake. He's putting it in the freezer. He's so proud of himself.
He did it. But then he hears Dwight.
yelling, screaming at Kelly.
Right in her face. Dwight does this. Remember when he got right in Phyllis' face?
Yes. Did they laugh a lot during this scene? I don't know how Mindy kept it together.
我肯定。好的。嗯，德怀特审问凯莉的原因是上周他查看了她的档案，试图弄清楚她确切的生日是什么时候，结果发现她14岁时进过少管所。现在他想知道为什么。我有一件事必须提出来。我不知道为什么这让我这么困扰，但这完全困扰了我。我做了那种暂停电视并和电视说话的事情。什么？我自己。什么？我暂停了它，我说，“她的名字的正确拼写难道不会在她的少年拘留记录上吗？”我也这么想。伙计们，在这一集的后面，吉姆会拼错她的名字在蛋糕上，我想，“天哪。”
I'm sure. All right. Well, the reason Dwight is interrogating Kelly is because last week he looked in her
files, trying to figure out when her exact birthday was, and he finds out that she was in juvie
when she was 14. And now he wants to know why.
I have one thing I have to bring up. I don't know why this bugged me so much, but it totally bugged me.
I did that thing where I paused the TV and I talked to the TV.
What?
By myself. What? I paused it and I said, wouldn't the correct spelling of her name been on her juvenile detention record?
I thought the same thing. Guys, later in the episode, Jim is going to misspell her name on the cake and I thought, my goodness.
是啊，他有一个完整的谈话头镜头。还是不知道怎么拼她的名字。也许看看德怀特手里的表格？我不知道，伙计们。听着，吉姆和德怀特不是好的沟通者。他们不分享信息。显然。他们没有。嗯，吉姆要试图通过给她看这个生日蛋糕来让凯莉高兴起来。他很自豪。谁在角落里潜伏着看着这一切？菲利斯。蛋糕是空白的。上面什么都没有。没有主题。她讨厌它。我不知道为什么，但我受到启发去了解冰淇淋蛋糕的历史。你在开玩笑吗？不。
Yeah, he has a whole talking head. Still don't know how to spell her.
name. Maybe look on the form in Dwight's hand? I don't know, guys. Listen, Jim and Dwight are not good
communicators. They're not sharing information. Clearly. They're not. Well, Jim is going to try to cheer
Kelly up by showing her this birthday cake. He's so proud of. Who's lurking in the corner watching the
whole thing? Phyllis. The cake is blank. There's nothing on it. There's no theme. She hates it.
I don't know why, but I became inspired to learn the history of the ice cream cake.
Are you kidding?
No.
这是一个好地方吗？还有比这更好的地方吗？嗯，给你。食物历史学家？那是一份工作。食物历史学家。哦，迷人。他们真的做吗？
Is this a good place for it?
Is there ever been a better place for it?
Well, here you go.
Food historians?
That's a job.
Food historian.
Oh, fascinating.
They do.
他们只是研究食物？我猜。我有点想成为一个。我想见一个。嗯，食物历史学家相信冰淇淋蛋糕是在1600年代末发明的。谁发明的？不清楚。食谱可以追溯到1870年代，冰淇淋蛋糕最初是由饼干和奶油制成的。在维多利亚时代，这些甜点被称为“炸弹”，它们由冰淇淋和水果组成，放在一个花哨的模具里。
They just study food?
I guess.
I kind of want to be one.
I want to meet one.
Well, food historian.
believe that ice cream cakes were invented at the end of the 1600s. Who invented it? It's unclear.
The recipes date back to the 1870s, and ice cream cakes were originally made from biscuits and cream.
In the Victorian era, the desserts were called bombs, and they consisted of ice cream and fruit in a fancy mold.
所以它经历了许多排列组合。在早期，它被认为是一种奢侈品，只有富人才能享用，因为他们是唯一能保持它寒冷的人。对。你必须弄到一块冰。是的。现在，冰淇淋蛋糕的表亲是“烤阿拉斯加”。那是被蛋白酥皮包围的冷冻奶油，但它是热着上的，里面没有蛋糕。真正的冰淇淋蛋糕有三层。
So it went through many permutations.
In its early days, it was considered quite a luxury item,
and it was only enjoyed by the wealthy because they were the only people who could keep it cold.
Right. You'd have to get a block of ice.
Yes.
Now, the ice cream cake's cousin would be a baked Alaska.
That is frozen cream surrounded by meringue, but then it served hot, and there's no cake in it.
A true ice cream cake has three layers.
它有冰淇淋、蛋糕或饼干，然后是糖霜或鲜奶油。在美国，让冰淇淋蛋糕变得普及和流行的领导者是……我可以猜吗？我可以猜吗？芭斯罗缤。卡维尔！福吉鲸鱼！福吉鲸鱼，女士！
It has ice cream, cake or biscuits, and then icing or whipped cream.
The leader in America for making the ice cream cake accessible and popular is...
Can I guess?
Baskin Robbins.
Carville!
Fudgy the whale!
Fudgy the whale, lady!
哦，我为什么没预料到？听着，我刚和孩子们在芭斯罗缤，因为他们想要放学后的零食。口味太多了。哦，是的。我喜欢芭斯罗缤的冰淇淋蛋糕。但它是从卡维尔开始的，软冰淇淋。是的。
Oh, why didn't I see that coming?
Listen, I was just at Baskin Robbins with the kids because they wanted like after-school
snack.
There's so many flavors.
Oh, yeah.
I love a Baskin-Robbins ice cream cake.
But it started with Carvel, soft-serve.
Yes.
就是这样。这是一个关于冰淇淋蛋糕的小历史，但这就是它。嗯，你知道由此产生了什么吗？什么？我需要见一位食物历史学家。我的意思是，真的吗？把它写在我的清单上。我必须说，当我们谈论冰淇淋蛋糕的历史时，我不知道你是否注意到了，
That's it.
It was a small history of ice cream cake, but there you have it.
Well, you know what came out of that?
What?
My need to meet a food historian.
I mean, really?
Put it on my list.
I have to say, while we were talking about the history of the ice cream cake, I don't know if you noticed this,
但我们变得真的很，有点像，哦，哇。就像那是非常珍贵的信息。感觉确实是。它让我发痒。我被逗乐了。当我们真的很投入某件事时，我们会变得很安静。我知道它的重要性。说到重要性，帕姆和迈克尔已经到达了纳舒厄分公司。
but we got really, like, kind of like, oh, wow.
like it was very precious information.
It felt like it was.
It is tickling me.
I am tickled.
When we're really into something, we get real quiet.
I know the importance of it.
Speaking of importance, Pam and Michael have arrived at the Nashua branch.
嗯，我们要做的第一件事就是拍照。必须拍照。我们在记录这个。迈克尔进入时非常紧张。他们受到了一位非常好的接待员的迎接。她告诉他们霍莉不在那儿。不，她去参加为期三天的HR静修了。但如果你真的需要联系她，你可以和那边的男友谈谈。
Well, the first thing we're going to do is take a picture.
Got to take a picture.
We're documenting this.
Michael's very nervous as they enter.
They're greeted by a really nice receptionist.
You tells them that Holly is not there.
No, she's on an HR retreat for three days.
But if you really need to get in touch with her, you can just talk to her boyfriend over there.
A.J.，销售员。珍娜，我再次暂停了电视并不得不和它说话，因为我想，“霍莉，你刚因为和同事约会而被公司调职。是啊。现在你去了公司的新分公司，又立即开始和另一个同事约会？”我甚至没把这联系起来。我甚至没想过。这就是他们把她调到纳舒厄的全部原因。
AJ, salesman.
Jenna, I again, pause the TV and had to talk to it because I thought,
Holly, you just got transferred by corporate because you were dating a coworker.
Yeah.
And now you go to this new branch of your company and immediately start dating another coworker?
I didn't even put that together.
I didn't even think of that.
It's the whole reason they moved her to Nashua.
AJ，销售员。Jenna，我再次暂停了电视，不得不对着它说话，因为我想，Holly，你刚因为和同事约会被公司调职。是的。现在你去了公司的新分部，又立刻开始和另一个同事约会？我甚至没把这两件事联系起来。我根本没往那方面想。这正是他们把她调到Nashua的全部原因。
Yeah, you're right.
And she works in HR.
I mean, if anyone should be on top of this, it's her.
Holly.
Well, Angie, you mentioned that the receptionist was really nice to Michael and Pam, and we got mail about that.
Baranese C.
said the receptionist at Nashua branch is really friendly and happily.
expecting Michael's arrival.
是的，你说得对。而且她在人力资源部工作。我的意思是，如果有人应该处理好这件事，那肯定就是她。霍莉。嗯，安吉，你提到前台接待员对迈克尔和帕姆非常友好，我们收到了关于此事的邮件。Baranese C. 说纳舒厄分部的前台接待员非常友好，而且很高兴迈克尔的到来。
She said, maybe they really don't get very many visitors, like Pam said.
I think they don't.
I think they're the forgotten about branch.
That's what Pam said earlier.
Well, the receptionist was played by actress Catherine Flynn.
Just wanted to give her a shout out for her friendly greeting.
Michael has to get outside for some air.
He is not doing well.
她说，也许他们真的像帕姆说的那样，没接待过多少访客。我想他们确实没有。我觉得他们是被遗忘的分部。这就是帕姆之前说的。嗯，前台接待员是由女演员凯瑟琳·弗林饰演的。只是想对她友好的问候表示感谢。迈克尔得去外面透透气。他状态不太好。
No, he is about to fall apart.
Yeah.
In this scene, I wanted to make two observations.
Okay. Okay. One is it was really hard for me to sit on that curb and a pencil skirt and heels. And I think I did a good job. It really is hard to sit on a curb like in any kind of skirt like that. Because your legs don't really have anywhere to go. Yep. You can't bunch under. No. And I had to like tuck my hands under to keep the skirt up from flapping down. Yeah. Second, I have a windshield.
wiper hair going back and forth on my forehead during this entire exchange. A little hair
that just goes, pshush, pshu-sh-ish. Yep, the whole scene. And on a normal television show,
they would have cut, and they would have had someone come in and just shalack, just spray it down.
We don't want any flyaways. And they would have been like holding for hair. They would have
不，他快要崩溃了。是的。在这一幕中，我想观察两点。好的。好的。第一点是，我穿着铅笔裙和高跟鞋坐在路边真的很困难。我觉得我表现得不错。穿着那种裙子坐在路边确实很难。因为你的腿真的没地方放。是的。你不能把裙子塞在下面。不能。我不得不把手塞在下面，防止裙子往上翻。是的。第二，在整个交流过程中，我的额头上有一缕头发像雨刷一样来回摆动。那一小缕头发就在那儿，噗，噗。是的，整个场景都是这样。在普通的电视节目中，他们会喊停，然后让人进来，用发胶把它固定住。我们不希望有任何乱发。他们会喊“发型师就位”。他们会
actually said flying in for a fly away. But we didn't do that on our show. We just let stuff happen.
I thought maybe this is one time, since it was such an emotional scene, maybe, maybe we should have shellacted.
Were you distracted by your windshield wiper hair? A little. You didn't notice it. I did not notice it.
But now it will be all I can see when I rewatch it. Yeah, enjoy that, everyone.
Well, lady, I think we should take a break because we're going to get into the thick of Angela's cats and Michael's presentation soon.
And I need to center myself before both those things happen.
I think you do because I might have stories about how I created this.
It was very good.
实际上会说“快来处理一下乱发”。但我们的节目没这么做。我们只是顺其自然。我当时想，也许这是唯一一次，因为这是一个如此感人的场景，也许，也许我们应该用发胶固定一下。你的“雨刷”头发让你分心了吗？有一点。你没注意到。我没注意到。但现在我重看的时候，只能看到那个了。是的，大家尽情享受吧。好了，女士，我想我们该休息一下了，因为我们很快就要深入探讨安吉拉的猫和迈克尔的演讲了。在进入这两个话题之前，我需要调整一下状态。我想你需要，因为我可能有一些关于我是如何创作这些情节的故事。那非常好。
Thank you.
Hey, y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair.
Ever order furniture online and wonder what if?
Like, what if it doesn't hold up?
That sofa was four days old.
You should have ordered from Wayfair.
With Wayfair, there's no what if.
Just style you love and quality you can trust.
谢谢。嘿，大家好，我是Wayfair的凯莉·克拉克森。有没有在网上订购过家具，然后想“万一呢”？比如，万一它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你应该从Wayfair订购。在Wayfair，没有“万一”。只有你喜欢的风格和值得信赖的品质。
Visit wayfair.ca.
Wayfair, every style, every home.
We are back in Scranton, and Kevin hears,
what is happening on Angela's computer screen?
A lot's happening.
Mr. Ash is humping Princess Lady.
Oh.
Angel's like, these are decent cats.
访问wayfair.ca。Wayfair，每种风格，每个家。我们回到了斯克兰顿，凯文听到了，安吉拉的电脑屏幕上发生了什么？发生了很多事。阿什先生正在骑在公主女士身上。哦。安吉拉说，这些都是正经猫。
Don't, you know, make an assumption about them.
And Mr. Ash is fixed.
And Meredith's like, mono fixed and that ain't fixed.
Meredith. Meredith and her like super gulp from 7-Eleven with her sidebar comments.
Angela is so upset she has to leave.
Mm-hmm.
She has to go check on her cats.
Yes.
别，你知道，对它们做出那种假设。而且阿什先生已经绝育了。梅雷迪思说，没绝育，那可没绝育。梅雷迪思。梅雷迪思和她从7-Eleven买的超大杯饮料，还有她的旁白评论。安吉拉非常心烦，她必须离开。嗯哼。她得去看看她的猫。是的。
Make sure Princess Lady is okay.
And now, Jenna, for the Cat Guestar Breakdown.
Let's hear it.
Here we go.
Once again, we reached out to Bob Dunn's animal rentals in Silmar, California.
They are going to help us create this whole cat-humping scene.
But first, let me tell you who played Princess Lady.
Who?
确保公主女士没事。现在，珍娜，该进行猫咪客串演员的盘点了。让我们听听吧。开始了。我们再次联系了加利福尼亚州希尔马的鲍勃·邓恩动物租赁公司。他们将帮助我们完成这整场猫咪交配的戏。但首先，让我告诉你谁扮演了公主女士。谁？
Princess Lady was a Persian cat named Potato.
Oh.
You might have seen her if you watched the deleted scenes in the duel.
She was in them but not featured.
Oh.
Also, Mr. Ash, the other cat in this relationship, was played by Roswell.
Roswell!
Yes!
公主女士是一只名叫“土豆”的波斯猫。哦。如果你看过《决斗》的删减片段，你可能见过她。她在里面，但不是主角。哦。还有，这段关系中的另一只猫，阿什先生，是由罗斯威尔扮演的。罗斯威尔！是的！
The orange cat that looks like Sunny!
That's right.
I remember him from your cathead shots for the duel.
Now, I guess it's good that we deleted that scene.
because we could bring Potato back now for this lead role.
Right.
Yes.
那只看起来像桑尼的橘猫！没错。我记得她在你的《决斗》猫咪头像拍摄中出现过。没错。现在，我想删掉那场戏是件好事，因为我们现在可以带“土豆”回来担任这个主角了。对。是的。
Potato went from a background player to the lead of the scene.
Wow.
Princess Lady.
I mean, that's what happens in Hollywood.
That's right.
You go out for one role.
You're like, oh, I didn't get it.
And then you get Princess Lady.
“土豆”从背景演员变成了这场戏的主角。哇。公主女士。我的意思是，这就是好莱坞会发生的事。没错。你去试镜一个角色。你心想，哦，我没选上。然后你就成了公主女士。
Well, Randy said he loved how Bob Dunn's company listed the cats in the proposed budget.
We had seven milling about cats and two sex cats.
So seven background performers and then two leads.
Roswell and Potato.
Our head animal trainer was Denise Sanders.
She had been with us on stress relief.
She said she required several days of training to get Roswell to pull off a believable kitty
humping scene.
嗯，兰迪说他很喜欢鲍勃·邓恩的公司在拟议预算中列出猫咪的方式。我们有七只闲逛的猫和两只交配的猫。所以是七个背景演员，然后是两个主角。罗斯威尔和“土豆”。我们的首席动物训练师是丹妮丝·桑德斯。她曾和我们一起参与过《压力缓解》的拍摄。她说她需要几天的训练才能让罗斯威尔完成一场可信的猫咪交配戏。
How did she do that?
I don't know.
The overall cost of the advanced training plus the cats for the shoot,
days and then the trainer fees was just shy of $9,000. Wow. To get Mr. Ash to hump Princess Lady,
nine grand. That was a lot. I mean, I feel like I want to call that woman. What was her name?
The trainer's name? Denise. Denise. And I want to be like, how did you do it? Was it a series of treats like
every time Roswell stepped on potato, you got a treat? And then how do you get potato to stay put?
I don't know. I don't know.
她是怎么做到的？我不知道。高级训练加上拍摄当天的猫咪费用，还有训练师的费用，总共差一点就9000美元了。哇。为了让阿什先生骑在公主女士身上，九千块。那可真不少。我的意思是，我觉得我想给那个女人打个电话。她叫什么名字？训练师的名字？丹妮丝。丹妮丝。我想问她，你是怎么做到的？是一系列的奖励吗？比如每次罗斯威尔踩在“土豆”身上，你就给它奖励？然后你是怎么让“土豆”保持不动的？我不知道。我不知道。
These are questions for Denise.
Do we need Denise on?
I want Denise on.
And then I want an episode where we talk to a food historian.
Odd jobs with Jenna and Angela.
Yes.
Another spinoff podcast.
We have so many.
这些问题得问丹妮丝。我们需要请丹妮丝来吗？我想请丹妮丝来。然后我想做一集节目，采访一位食物历史学家。珍娜和安吉拉的奇葩工作。是的。又一个衍生播客。我们有太多了。
We have so many podcasts to do.
Oh, my goodness.
We have so many factories to tour and podcasts to do.
Well, listen, lady, I think we should stick with the cats here because I'm liking it.
Okay.
I'm liking the cat info.
You want to see the whole story.
I do.
我们有太多的播客要做。哦，天哪。我们有太多的工厂要参观，太多的播客要做。好吧，听着，女士，我想我们还是坚持聊猫吧，因为我挺喜欢的。好的。我喜欢关于猫的信息。你想看完整的故事。我想看。
Okay. Because back in Scranton, Kevin and Oscar are working in accounting, and they're going to hear Angela's voice. She's gotten home, and she is scolding Mr. Ash for his behavior. They have to watch.
She didn't turn her computer off. She forgot to turn the kitty cam off. She did. They are watching her. She's hissing. She is communicating with the cats, with meows. And then she grooms Princess Lady with her own tongue.
There are so many things to unpack in this moment for you.
First of all, I just love that she's like, excuse me, Pedals.
I'm looking for Mr. Ash.
Well, there you go.
We know another cat's name is Peddles.
But I don't think that's the question on everyone's minds, Ange.
好的。因为回到斯克兰顿，凯文和奥斯卡正在会计部工作，他们听到了安吉拉的声音。她已经到家了，正在责骂阿什先生的行为。他们不得不看。她没关电脑。她忘了关猫咪摄像头。她确实忘了。他们正在看着她。她在发出嘶嘶声。她正在用喵喵声与猫交流。然后她用自己的舌头给公主女士梳毛。这一刻有太多东西可以让你细品了。首先，我真的很喜欢她说“不好意思，佩德尔斯。我在找阿什先生”。好吧，就是这样。我们知道另一只猫的名字叫佩德尔斯。但我觉得那不是大家心里想问的问题，安吉。
And I know that because we got a lot of mail about it.
My favorite one was from Katie D who said, I don't even know where to start.
So, Angela, the cat cam scene, please explain.
Well, Katie, let me tell you.
Ken said to me, I want you to know, you don't have to lick a cat today.
Oh, yeah.
He said, camera's going to be far away.
I said, Ken, are you sure?
我知道这一点，因为我们收到了很多关于此事的邮件。我最喜欢的一封来自凯蒂·D，她说：“我甚至不知道从何说起。所以，安吉拉，猫咪摄像头那一幕，请解释一下。”好吧，凯蒂，让我告诉你。肯对我说：“我想让你知道，你今天不必舔猫。”哦，是的。他说：“摄像机会离得很远。”我说：“肯，你确定吗？”
He goes, yeah, yeah, no, you're not going to have to lick a cat today.
No.
I was like, oh, okay.
He goes, you can fake it.
We'll be able to sell it.
I said, okay.
So we do a few takes.
And he comes up to me kind of meekishly, and I said, Ken.
他说：“是的，是的，不，你今天不需要舔猫。”不。我说：“哦，好吧。”他说：“你可以假装。我们能演出来。”我说：“好吧。”所以我们拍了几条。然后他有点羞怯地走过来，我说：“肯。”
And he goes, we're just kind of moving a little bit closer with the camera.
I said, I knew it.
I knew it.
So in one take, I actually lick the cat's face.
I did it.
And I felt bad for the cat because the cat's eyes were like, you know.
Did you get hair in your mouth?
他说：“我们只是把摄像机稍微移近了一点。”我说：“我就知道。我就知道。我就知道。”所以其中一条，我真的舔了猫的脸。我做了。我为那只猫感到难过，因为猫的眼神就像是，你知道的。你嘴里吃到毛了吗？
Yes, of course I did.
It was a very hairy cat.
Did it taste weird?
I don't remember it tasting anyway, just being fuzzy.
Mm-hmm.
Randy told me that just in case I might lick the cat, listen, these guys knew they were going
to ask me all along.
They knew it.
是的，当然吃了。那是一只毛很多的猫。味道奇怪吗？我不记得有什么味道，只是感觉毛茸茸的。嗯哼。兰迪告诉我，以防万一我真的要舔猫，听着，这些人一直都知道他们会要求我这么做。他们知道的。
You think so?
Oh, yeah.
I think so.
I think they were going to try to get one shot.
Yeah.
You think?
Randy said, so in case you were going to have to maybe lick the cat, Denise Sanders, the trainer,
你这么认为？哦，是的。我想是的。我想他们会试着拍一条真的。是的。你觉得呢？是的。兰迪说，所以以防万一你可能不得不舔猫，丹妮丝·桑德斯，那位训练师，
gave potato a special bath and blow dry before she came to set that day.
Oh.
Potato got a blow out, fresh shower.
Well, that's nice.
Mm-hmm.
So yes, I did lick the cat, but only once. The rest of them were faky licks. I guess as the camera pans in, I don't know which one's the real one. So you don't know if they use the real lick or the fake lick? I don't know. Oh. Now, why would the camera be able to pan in if it was like a nanny cam? You'd think it would just be one locked off shot. Yes. You know. These are things I should have brought up in the moment. I should have had you with me. We did a lot of rehearsals. They were pitching different things.
to me that Angela would do to try to bond with her cats, crawl on the ground, roll over, pretend to
groom myself.
在那天带“土豆”来片场之前，给它做了特别的洗澡和吹干。哦。土豆做了个造型，洗了个澡。嗯，那真不错。嗯哼。所以是的，我确实舔了猫，但只有一次。其余的都是假舔。我想随着摄像机推近，我不知道哪一个是真的。所以你不知道他们用的是真舔还是假舔？我不知道。哦。现在，如果那是个保姆摄像头，摄像机怎么能推近呢？你以为那应该是一个固定的镜头。是的。你知道的。这些是我当时应该提出来的问题。我当时应该让你陪着我。我们排练了很多次。他们向我提议了各种安吉拉会做的事情，试图与她的猫建立联系，在地上爬，打滚，假装给自己梳毛。
And then they were like, does Angela talk to her cats?
How does she talk to her cats?
And then they pitched the sort of hiss thing.
And then I had to practice different hissies, guys.
They were very good.
I thought your cat sounds were great.
Thank you.
I mean, I feel like Ken and I really bonded this day because I was like, Ken, tell me, what do you like?
然后他们问：“安吉拉会和她的猫说话吗？她怎么和她的猫说话？”然后他们提议了那种嘶嘶声。然后我不得不练习不同的嘶嘶声，伙计们。它们非常棒。我觉得你的猫叫声很棒。谢谢。我的意思是，我觉得肯和我那天真的建立了联系，因为我说：“肯，告诉我，你喜欢哪一个？”
Do you like this one?
Or do you like, or do you like, shh?
Yeah.
And then he would be like, oh, I like the second.
And I'm like, okay.
I like it that you scolded your cats in their own language.
Thank you.
I thought it showed your bond with them.
“你喜欢这个吗？还是你喜欢，或者你喜欢，嘘？”是的。然后他会说：“哦，我喜欢第二个。”我说：“好的。”我喜欢你用猫的语言责骂它们。谢谢。我觉得这展示了你与它们的纽带。
Jenna, this brought me down a rabbit hole of Googling.
Do people really lick their cats?
Apparently, if you foster kittens, some people share online that they have licked a kitten's face if it's separated from its mom.
What do you know about this?
You foster kittens.
I've done it.
You've licked a cat's face.
face. I have. I knew it. I was like, I bet Jenna has looked a cat's face. Yeah. So I worked in cat fostering for three years. Yeah. And I fostered many kittens who had been separated from their moms at a very, very young age. And, you know, I'm trying to socialize them. And I would just lick them between their eyes on their little forehead. Give them a few little licks. That's what I read. Yes. Not with adult cats, but with little kittens. With kittens. That are very young and
珍娜，这让我陷入了谷歌搜索的兔子洞。人们真的会舔他们的猫吗？显然，如果你寄养小猫，有些人会在网上分享说，如果小猫和妈妈分开了，他们会舔小猫的脸。你知道这个吗？你寄养过小猫。我做过。你舔过猫的脸。脸。我舔过。我就知道。我心想，我敢打赌珍娜舔过猫的脸。是的。所以我做了三年的猫咪寄养工作。是的。我寄养过许多在很小的时候就与妈妈分开的小猫。而且，你知道，我试图让它们社会化。我会舔它们两眼之间的小额头。给它们舔几下。这就是我读到的。是的。不是成年猫，而是小猫。小猫。非常年幼且
separated from their mom. Yes. And it brings some great comfort and they purr. That's what I read.
I knew you would know. And I will say, I have also licked an adult cat. Okay.
My cat, Andy, he had been sick and he was an adult. And I licked between his eyes to give him some
comfort. So, yeah. I don't know. I mean, people let their dogs lick their faces and I don't know.
When you have a pet, they become like a member of the family.
I think it's kind of like, listen, I'm not going to go over to anyone's house and start licking their animals.
And I don't love when someone else's dog licks my face, but I don't care when my own dog does it.
Right?
与妈妈分开了。是的。这会带来极大的安慰，它们会发出呼噜声。这就是我读到的。我就知道你会知道。而且我要说，我也舔过成年猫。好的。我的猫，安迪，它生病了，它是一只成年猫。我舔了它两眼之间，给它一些安慰。所以，是的。我不知道。我的意思是，人们让他们的狗舔他们的脸，我不知道。当你有一只宠物时，它们就像家庭成员一样。我觉得这有点像，听着，我不会去别人家开始舔他们的动物。而且我不喜欢别人的狗舔我的脸，但我不介意我自己的狗舔我。对吧？
Just like how your own kid's poop and vomit doesn't bother you, but I don't want some other kid to poop on me.
Well, no.
I don't know what that is.
I don't know why.
It's like when it's your family, you don't care.
Well, I want you to know, when I look this up online, there's a big debate about when and where and how to.
bond by licking your cat. Okay. And also, guys, apparently there's a whole industry of fake tongues
that humans can purchase. Yes. To lick their cats. Okay. So yes. There's also a little thing that you can put
就像你自己的孩子拉屎呕吐你都不介意，但我不想让别人的孩子拉在我身上。嗯，不。我不知道那是什么。我不知道为什么。就像当它是你的家人时，你就不在乎了。嗯，我想让你知道，当我在网上查这个时，关于何时、何地以及如何通过舔猫来建立联系，有一个很大的争论。好的。而且伙计们，显然有一个完整的假舌头产业，人类可以购买。是的。用来舔他们的猫。好的。所以是的。还有一个小东西你可以放在
on your finger that's like sort of meant to simulate an adult cat's tongue. And if you foster kittens,
you can get that and then you can like rub that between their eyes. That's a thing you can get to.
Cassie's in the booth. Cassie, you just fostered a bunch of kittens. Did you lick any of them?
I didn't. I didn't know this was a thing, but maybe next round I'll try it.
Or you can just get the little fingerbrush thing. That came out while I was like mid-fustering, and I did move to the fingerbrush eventually.
Yeah, I'll get that. There was one that haunted me. It's a thing that you can, well, I won't be able to unsee it.
It's a fake tongue that you can put in your mouth like a pacifier. Why? And then you can,
It can just be on your finger.
你的手指上，旨在模拟成年猫的舌头。如果你寄养小猫，你可以得到那个，然后你可以用它在它们两眼之间摩擦。那也是你可以得到的东西。凯西在录音室里。凯西，你刚寄养了一堆小猫。你舔过它们吗？我没有。我不知道还有这种事，但也许下一轮我会试试。或者你可以只用那个小指套刷。那东西在我寄养期间出来了，我最终确实换成了指套刷。是的，我会买那个。有一个东西困扰着我。这是一个你可以，好吧，我无法忘记它。这是一个假舌头，你可以像奶嘴一样放在嘴里。为什么？然后你可以，它可以就在你的手指上。
That's what she said.
I'm showing, Jenna.
Oh, my God.
Introducing licky brush.
I'm sorry.
As a...
As a human, you're left out of this intimate ritual.
With licky brush, you can now...
她就是这么说的。我正在展示，珍娜。哦，天哪。介绍一下“舔舔刷”。对不起。作为一个……作为一个人类，你被排除在这个亲密的仪式之外了。有了“舔舔刷”，你现在可以……
It's also, it's also...
They have like a...
Like a...
A big musly man with a licky brush in his mouth.
A pacify.
It's a pacifier that has a tongue on it, and he's cradling his cow like a baby and then like licking it.
And it's just that they picked someone I would not expect.
它也是，它也是……他们有一个……像一个……像一个……一个大块头男人嘴里含着“舔舔刷”。一个奶嘴。这是一个带有舌头的奶嘴，他像抱婴儿一样抱着他的猫，然后舔它。他们选了一个我完全没料到的人。
I mean, I want you to know.
I saw that, and I have been waiting to show you.
I was like, I'm not even going to tell her.
I want her to see it.
I want to watch her react to it because I was like, what was happening?
What did I just click on?
Wow.
Okay. Well, I guess it can take the idea of bonding with your cat to a whole new level.
我的意思是，我想让你知道。我看到了那个，我一直等着给你看。我心想，我甚至不告诉她。我想让她看到。我想看她的反应，因为我当时想，发生了什么？我刚才点了什么？哇。好吧。嗯，我想这可以把与猫建立联系的想法提升到一个全新的水平。
They make them for your fingers, is what I want to say.
To finish out this cat storyline, Angela returns to the office.
Yes.
And she sees her computer as on, and she's like, oh, my gosh, has that been on the whole time?
And Kevin and Oscar are like, what?
I don't, we were just, we don't have no idea.
what you're talking about. Oscar has a talking head where he says he needs to erase that image
from his head. But then Angela coughs up a hairball. Well, let's hear about that. I cough up a tiny
我想说的是，他们也为你的手指制作了这种东西。为了结束这个猫咪剧情，安吉拉回到了办公室。是的。她看到她的电脑开着，她说：“哦，天哪，它一直开着吗？”凯文和奥斯卡说：“什么？我不知道，我们只是，我们完全不知道你在说什么。”奥斯卡有一个采访镜头，他说他需要从脑海中抹去那个画面。但随后安吉拉咳出了一个毛球。好吧，让我们听听那个。我咳出了一个小
hair, guys, right? It's like a little hair. But you know what? You've had your cat like cough up a
hairball, right? It's so violent. It's like, yeah. It's so, it's so. It's so. It's so
incredibly like the first time you get a cat and they do it you're like oh my god i don't know what's happening
it's so intense so once again can and i and mindy we're talking about how big do you go here right how big
do i really because you have two choices either angel martin has to do that like uh-huh yeah thing
or it's like way more subtle and so i practiced a few different ways and this is the one they liked
where basically I'm just pulling one hair off my tongue.
And it's like, what is it?
毛，伙计们，对吧？就像一根小毛。但你知道吗？你见过你的猫咳出毛球，对吧？太暴力了。就像，是的。太，太。太。太不可思议了，就像你第一次养猫，它们做这件事时，你会想“哦，天哪，我不知道发生了什么”，太强烈了。所以再一次，肯和我还有明迪在讨论，这里要演到什么程度，对吧？我到底要演多大？因为你有两个选择，要么安吉拉·马丁必须做那种“嗯哼”的事，要么就是更微妙一点。所以我练习了几种不同的方式，这是他们喜欢的一种，基本上我只是从舌头上拉出一根头发。然后就像，那是什么？
Was it the cat?
Is it something else?
It was the cat.
But I had to do it enough to sell it to Oscar and not so much that it was like a total cartoon.
That was my work day, guys.
That was my day that day.
是猫吗？是别的东西吗？是猫。是猫。是猫。但我必须演得足够真实，才能骗过奥斯卡，又不能演得太夸张，像个卡通片。那就是我的工作日，伙计们。那就是我那天的一天。
Hey, you're going to crawl around on the ground, pretend to be a cat, hiss at cats, lick a cat, and then cough up a hairball.
Mom, would you do at work today?
Welcome to Hollywood.
Should we go to Nashua?
We do because Pam has talked Michael into giving his presentation.
Because then maybe they'll all talk about how great Michael was and Holly will hear about it, right?
That's the way you show AJ, right?
Yes.
嘿，你要在地上爬，假装是一只猫，对猫发出嘶嘶声，舔一只猫，然后咳出一个毛球。妈妈，你今天在工作做了什么？欢迎来到好莱坞。我们去纳舒厄吗？我们去了，因为帕姆说服迈克尔去进行他的演讲。因为这样也许他们都会谈论迈克尔有多棒，霍莉也会听到，对吧？这就是你向AJ展示的方式，对吧？是的。
And you know what?
At the beginning, it's going great.
It is.
He's doing a fantastic job.
Just listen to all of his movie references.
Good morning, Vietnam, Nashville.
up. Sales. Sales is what brings us together today. How do we deal with clients who say,
frankly, my dear, I don't give a damn about paper, and get them to show us the money.
你知道吗？一开始，一切都很顺利。确实。他做得非常出色。只要听听他所有的电影引用。早安，越南，纳舒厄。向上。销售。销售是今天把我们聚在一起的原因。我们如何处理那些说“坦白说，亲爱的，我一点也不在乎纸张”的客户，并让他们向我们展示金钱？
Well, we are going to find out today. I had written this down. It's so interesting that you
played that clip because I wondered, do our younger viewers get all of the references in Michael's opening
remarks? Do they know these movies? Good morning, Vietnam, Princess Bride, Gone with the Wind,
and Jerry McGuire. I guess this is Michael's taste in movies. But do people know all those today?
I mean, you've got to know Princess Bride, right? I think. I don't know. I don't know. But he's got
them. They're laughing. They love his, like, voices he's doing. Nashville likes Michael, from the receptionist
to his opening remarks, they're eating out of the palm of his hand. If only he could get over this
holly thing, he would finally have a day where he was the king of comedy like he's always wanted.
嗯，我们今天就会知道。我把这个写下来了。你播放那个片段非常有趣，因为我很好奇，我们年轻的观众能听懂迈克尔开场白中的所有引用吗？他们知道这些电影吗？《早安，越南》、《公主新娘》、《乱世佳人》和《甜心先生》。我想这就是迈克尔的电影品味。但今天人们都知道所有这些吗？我的意思是，你一定得知道《公主新娘》，对吧？我想。我不知道。我不知道。但他做到了。他们在笑。他们喜欢他做的那些声音。纳舒厄喜欢迈克尔，从前台接待员到他的开场白，他们都被他迷住了。如果他能克服霍莉这件事，他终于可以度过一天，成为他一直想成为的喜剧之王。
Those 30 seconds you just heard are the best that it is, because that's how quickly it falls apart.
Because Michael zeroes in on AJ. He can't help it.
salesman, salespeople.
He's going to pick a random salesperson.
You there, sir, you.
Mm-hmm.
What's it like to be you?
Oh, here we go.
你刚才听到的那30秒是最好的部分，因为崩溃发生得太快了。因为迈克尔盯上了AJ。他忍不住。推销员，销售人员。他要随便挑一个销售人员。你，先生，你。嗯哼。成为你是什么感觉？哦，开始了。
Yeah.
And then Michael has a full-on panic attack.
He winds up on the ground and he crawls out of the room.
Mm-hmm.
Leaving Pam.
Yeah.
Well, before we get to what Pam is going to do,
I wanted to shout out a few crew cameos.
是的。然后迈克尔彻底恐慌发作了。他最终倒在地上，爬出了房间。嗯哼。留下了帕姆。是的。好吧，在我们谈到帕姆要做什么之前，我想提一下几个剧组成员的客串。
Oh, okay.
So sitting next to AJ, the woman who asked the question about discounts from distributors, that was Mary Wall.
Yes.
And she was a member of our production staff.
And she is delightful and wonderful.
She has gone on to become a producer and a director.
She currently is working on a documentary called The Fan Connection.
You can actually check it out at Fan ConnectionMovie.com.
哦，好的。坐在AJ旁边，那个问关于分销商折扣问题的女人，那是玛丽·沃尔。是的。她是我们的制作人员之一。她非常令人愉快和出色。她后来成为了一名制片人和导演。她目前正在制作一部名为《粉丝连接》的纪录片。你实际上可以在FanConnectionMovie.com上查看它。
You can see a trailer.
It's all about the hockey fans in Buffalo.
Oh, I would love that. And their commitment to their hockey team, and you know I love hockey. So anyway,
check out the trailer, guys. I love sports documentaries. Love them. And then sitting in the row in front
of AJ with the red hair was Claire Scanlon, our editor. And Pam's going to call her freckles.
Claire is a full-on badass, amazing editor, and now prolific director. Yes. And then I have another guest star I want
mention Michael McCartney, he played the other Nashua employee who says, what does this have to do with
sales when Michael is disintegrating? He has a very extensive resume. He is the producer and director of the
你可以看到预告片。它是关于布法罗的曲棍球迷的。哦，我会很喜欢那个。以及他们对曲棍球队的忠诚，你知道我喜欢曲棍球。所以，总之，去看看预告片吧，伙计们。我喜欢体育纪录片。非常喜欢。然后坐在AJ前面那排红头发的是克莱尔·斯坎伦，我们的剪辑师。帕姆会叫她“雀斑”。克莱尔是一个彻头彻尾的狠角色，出色的剪辑师，现在是多产的导演。是的。然后我还有另一个客串明星我想提一下，迈克尔·麦卡特尼，他扮演了另一个纳舒厄员工，当迈克尔崩溃时，他说：“这和销售有什么关系？”他有非常丰富的简历。他是亚马逊Prime系列剧《百万富翁》的制片人和导演，但这是我想告诉你的。这是我第一次看到这个。在我对我们所有客串明星的谷歌搜索中，虽然现在我不知道该期待什么，迈克尔·麦卡特尼上过《法律与秩序》。好的。《法律与秩序：特殊受害者》。哦，好吧。还有《法律与秩序：犯罪倾向》，三连冠。天哪！
series The Millionaires on Amazon Prime, but here's what I want to tell you. This is the first time
I've seen this. And all of my Googling of all of our guest stars, while now I don't know what to expect,
Michael McCartney has been on law and order.
Okay.
Law and Order SVU.
Oh, well.
And Law and Order Criminal Intent, the trifecta.
Holy cow!
三个都上了。没上《神探阿蒙》。没上《神探阿蒙》。还有空间。未来的客串明星，如果你能上所有三个《法律与秩序》和《神探阿蒙》，我会开车去你家给你一个蛋糕。所以当我和罗布互通邮件时，我说：“罗布，你必须分享一下在那间屋子里是什么感觉”
All three.
Not on Monk.
There's still room.
Future guest star, if you could be on all three Law & Order's and Monk, I'm going to drive
to your house and give you a cake.
So when I was trading emails with Rob, I was like, Rob, you've got to share.
what it was like in that room
当史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔崩溃时。是的。并且专门针对你。我的意思是，我不知道。你是怎么做到的？你是怎么熬过来的？这就是他要说的。
when Steve, as Michael,
is falling apart.
Yes.
And singling you out.
I mean, I don't know.
How did you do that?
How did you get through it?
And here's what he had to say.
我对和史蒂夫在会议室拍摄那场戏的记忆，主要是关于尽量不笑，因为有时当人们很有趣时，我就会开始笑，因为真的，我觉得
My memories of shooting that scene
in the conference room with Steve
are mostly about just trying not to laugh
because sometimes I just start laughing
when people are funny
because really I feel.
like a lot of times on comedy shows, you're trying to make the other person laugh.
In a way, you're kind of trying to fuck with them a little bit.
在喜剧节目中，很多时候你是在试图让对方笑。在某种程度上，你是在试图捉弄他们。
So anyway, I was just trying to keep a straight face because Steve is so funny and Jenna is so
funny and everybody on the show is so funny.
And I also get very nervous.
I get nervous going into a new show and, you know, there's this whole other culture there
already established. When you're a guest actor on a show, it's different because you don't know
what you're walking into. So I was a little bit nervous, and Steve is just, you know, iconic.
Steve is just so funny. And when he's kind of coming at me like that, he's, you know,
putting me down and ignoring me and calling me names in a very funny way. But it's all so funny.
所以总之，我只是试图保持严肃，因为史蒂夫太搞笑了，珍娜也太搞笑了，节目里的每个人都太搞笑了。而且我也很紧张。我进入一个新节目时会感到紧张，你知道，那里已经建立了一套完全不同的文化。当你是一个节目的客串演员时，情况是不同的，因为你不知道你会遇到什么。所以我有点紧张，而史蒂夫，你知道，是标志性的。史蒂夫太搞笑了。当他那样针对我时，他，你知道，在贬低我，无视我，并以一种非常有趣的方式叫我的名字。但这都太搞笑了。
So mostly trying not to laugh.
I loved his description of what it's like to be a guest actor on a show.
Walking into the world and it's a comedy and it's supposed to be funny, but then you're not supposed to laugh.
I just, I related to all of that so much.
I did too.
Well, we also asked him, does he still get recognized as AJ?
He's been on, what did you say, 140?
140 movies and TV shows.
所以主要是尽量不笑。我喜欢他对作为客串演员的描述。走进那个世界，这是一部喜剧，它应该很有趣，但你又不应该笑。我真的，我和所有这些都产生了共鸣。我也一样。好吧，我们也问过他，他还会因为AJ这个角色被认出来吗？他演过，你刚才说，140部？140部电影和电视剧。
Does it get recognized as AJ?
Let's find out.
Do I get recognized as AJ from the office?
Are you kidding me?
Yes.
Yes, a lot.
And I'm so thankful for it.
It is very fun to be recognized, no matter what people tell you, it is fun.
他还会因为AJ被认出来吗？让我们看看。我还会因为《办公室》里的AJ被认出来吗？你在开玩笑吗？是的。是的，很多。我很感激。无论人们怎么说，被认出来都很有趣。
Because it's, you know, people love it.
They love the show.
and that's fun.
You know, like everyone had an opinion about Michael and Holly's relationship,
and I was just standing in the way,
so I would get threatened by strangers.
You know, it was crazy.
In fact, people used to come up to me out of the blue.
因为，你知道，人们喜欢它。他们喜欢这个节目。这很有趣。你知道，每个人对迈克尔和霍莉的关系都有看法，而我正好挡在中间，所以我会被陌生人威胁。你知道，这太疯狂了。事实上，人们过去常常突然走过来。
I remember people would sometimes whisper in my ear,
like come up behind me and say,
you stay away from Holly.
You stay away from Holly.
And what's crazy is that my wife in real life,
her name is Holly.
So I would have to decide in about two seconds, okay, is this someone that used to date my wife in real life that I should murder?
Or is this just a fan of the office acting like a creeper?
我记得人们有时会对着我的耳朵低语，比如从我身后走过来，说：“离霍莉远点。离霍莉远点。”最疯狂的是，我现实生活中的妻子，她的名字就叫霍莉。所以我必须在两秒钟内决定，好吧，这是以前和我现实生活中的妻子约会过的人，我应该杀了他吗？还是这只是一个像变态一样的《办公室》粉丝？
I love that his wife's name is Holly.
I know.
That's insane.
That is crazy, though, that people go up to him and they're like, leave Holly alone.
And he's like, wait, wait, that's my wife.
Oh, you're, oh, okay.
Oh, I know.
you are. Amazing. Well, thank you, Rob, for sending in your audio clips. It was so nice of you. I love listening
我喜欢他妻子的名字叫霍莉。我知道。那太疯狂了。不过，人们走过去对他说“离霍莉远点”确实很疯狂。而他心想，等等，等等，那是我的妻子。哦，你是，哦，好吧。哦，我知道。你是谁。太棒了。好吧，谢谢罗布发来你的音频片段。你真是太好了。我喜欢听
to your voice. I think he has a soothing, pleasant voice. Rob, she's not kidding. While we were recording
this episode and you sent in your audio clips, Jenna was like, I just love the sound of his voice.
I know. I hope you get tons of voiceover work, because I would buy anything you're selling.
Hey! Yeah. How about them apples? So Jenna, Michael has left. Pam is in charge.
She goes right into Forrest Gump.
Lady, this was one of my favorite shooting days ever, having to take over the presentation.
It was so fun to watch you.
It was hilarious.
你的声音。我觉得他有一个舒缓、悦耳的声音。罗布，她不是在开玩笑。当我们录制这一集，你发来音频片段时，珍娜说：“我就是喜欢他声音的质感。”我知道。我希望你能得到大量的配音工作，因为我会买你卖的任何东西。嘿！是的。那又怎么样呢？所以珍娜，迈克尔离开了。帕姆负责。她直接进入了《阿甘正传》。女士，这是我最喜欢的拍摄日之一，不得不接管演讲。看你表演太有趣了。太搞笑了。
I loved watching Pam try to do Michael's movie bits.
Angela, you know I'm not great with accents.
I know this.
Or impressions.
I cannot tell you how hard I worked on that Forrest Gump voice.
Oh my gosh, lady.
So hard.
Lady, I thought you were doing a bit to be bad, right?
我喜欢看帕姆尝试迈克尔的电影片段。安吉拉，你知道我不擅长口音。我知道这一点。或者模仿。我无法告诉你我在那个《阿甘正传》的声音上付出了多少努力。哦，天哪，女士。太努力了。女士，我以为你在故意演得很烂，对吧？
Yes.
And that is what Mindy and Ken Quappas thought on set.
They were crying, laughing when I did it.
Mindy said it was genius that I was doing it so bad.
Yeah.
And I was texting with her because I was like,
Mindy, do you remember this episode?
And she said, yes, I thought you were so funny that day.
是的。这就是明迪和肯·夸帕斯在片场想的。我做的时候他们笑得流泪了。明迪说我演得这么烂简直是天才。是的。我当时在和她发短信，因为我问：“明迪，你还记得这一集吗？”她说：“记得，我觉得你那天太搞笑了。”
You're Forrest Gump.
It was such a funny choice, you know, to be bad.
And I was like, Mindy, that was my literal best effort.
My acting limitations made me genius.
Like, that's one of those things where, like, if I tried to be bad,
it wouldn't have been as good as me giving it my best effort.
I can't do it better than that.
I need to hear it.
你的阿甘。这是一个非常有趣的选择，你知道，演得很烂。我说：“明迪，那是我尽了最大的努力。”我的表演局限性让我成了天才。就像，这是那种事情，如果我试图演得很烂，它就不会像我尽了最大努力那样好。我无法做得比那更好。我需要听听。
I need to hear it. I need to hear it. I got to hear it.
I'm getting my laptop.
I got to hear it.
I got, with that information in my brain, I've got to hear it because I thought,
Like Mindy, that you were doing a bit.
No.
At like, I'm going to read it.
My first gump kind of crappy.
我需要听听。我需要听听。我得听听。我去拿我的笔记本电脑。我得听听。我得，带着那个信息在脑子里，我得听听，因为我以为，像明迪一样，你在演一个片段。不。在像，我要读它。我的阿甘有点烂。
But no, it was your best effort, honey.
I listened to his voice in my head over and over and over and over again,
and I tried to mimic it perfectly.
I have never loved you more, knowing now that that forest gump was your earnest best effort.
It was.
Sales is like a box of chocolates.
You never know which.
vendor you're going to get.
但不，那是你尽了最大的努力，亲爱的。我在脑海里一遍又一遍地听他的声音，我试图完美地模仿它。我现在更爱你了，知道那个阿甘是你真诚的尽力而为。确实是。销售就像一盒巧克力。你永远不知道你会得到哪个。
Poor scump.
Lady, that's the cutest thing ever.
That is the cutest thing.
Oh my gosh.
Look at Devin and Cassie.
They're cracking up.
You guys, is that adorable?
Come on.
可怜的阿甘。女士，那是史上最可爱的事情。那是最可爱的事情。哦，天哪。看看德文和凯西。他们笑得前仰后合。你们，那不可爱吗？来吧。
So cute.
We love it.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
I loved doing that scene.
I loved the chainsaw.
It was one of my most, you know, this was one of the few times.
太可爱了。我们喜欢它。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢。我喜欢演那场戏。我喜欢电锯。我喜欢电锯。这是我最，你知道，这是为数不多的几次之一。
when I was called upon to do, like, what would you call it?
Like, lead the group?
To be the comedy protagonist.
Yes.
I was usually the receiver of comedy.
My job on this show was to amplify a comedic moment with my deadpan reaction.
But in this case, I got to pitch the comedy ball, and it felt really good.
Other people reacted off of you.
当我被要求做，你会怎么称呼它？比如，领导团队？成为喜剧主角。是的。我通常是喜剧的接收者。我在这个节目中的工作是通过我面无表情的反应来放大喜剧时刻。但在这种情况下，我得到了投掷喜剧球的机会，感觉非常好。其他人对你的反应做出回应。
Yes.
And it was fun.
Well, one of my favorite things to watch play out.
in any movie or TV show is when a character decides to step up to the plate and then bails.
So at the end, when Pam got out the chainsaw and was like,
me, cutting down the competition.
Yeah.
The bail is my favorite.
是的。这很有趣。好吧，在任何电影或电视剧中，我最喜欢看的情节之一就是当一个角色决定挺身而出，然后又退缩时。所以最后，当帕姆拿出电锯说：“我，砍掉竞争对手。”是的。那个退缩是我最喜欢的。
She's like, I'm out.
Well, during all this, Michael has gone over to Holly's desk.
He's stroking her yellow cardigan.
He cuts half of the sleeve off.
Yeah.
That made me laugh so hard, Jenna.
And then he, like, pushes the chair in, and this screensaver pops up of Martin Short, which is so perfect.
As Ed Grimley.
她说：“我不干了。”好吧，在这期间，迈克尔走到霍莉的桌子旁。他抚摸着她的黄色开衫。他剪掉了袖子的一半。是的。那让我笑得太厉害了，珍娜。然后他，就像，把椅子推回去，这个屏幕保护程序弹了出来，是马丁·肖特，这太完美了。饰演埃德·格里姆利。
Yes.
You know what?
Randy Cordray told me.
What?
That little moment.
Like, that was a whole thing.
He said we had this graphic artist on staff.
His name was Michael Marcus.
是的。你知道吗？兰迪·科德雷告诉我的。什么？那个小瞬间。就像，那是一整件事。他说我们有一个员工图形艺术家。他的名字叫迈克尔·马库斯。
And he had to build that on-screen computer graphic where there were these documents.
on the homepage, that picture of Martin Short, they had to get permission to license that photo
from Getty images.
I mean, that little moment, that was someone's day, creating that.
Right.
I love watching the show and thinking of those details.
Well, to finish out the Nashua Branch storyline, Pam and Michael, they pack up.
I love when Pam was like, don't look up, don't look up, don't look up, don't look up when
他必须在屏幕上制作那个电脑图形，上面有这些文档。在主页上，那张马丁·肖特的照片，他们必须获得许可才能从盖蒂图片社授权那张照片。我的意思是，那个小瞬间，那是某人的一天，创造那个。对。我喜欢看这个节目并思考那些细节。好吧，为了结束纳舒厄分部的剧情，帕姆和迈克尔，他们收拾行李。我喜欢帕姆说“别抬头，别抬头，别抬头，别抬头”的时候，当
they're packing up the car.
And they go to a diner.
And Michael confesses that, A, he cut off part of her sweater and that he saw a Dear Michael folder on her desktop and he copied it.
He's got it.
And Pam says, you can't read that, but I can read it.
Right.
Pam can read it.
And I won't tell you what the specifics are, but I can tell you if she still likes you.
他们在收拾车子。他们去了一家餐馆。迈克尔承认，A，他剪掉了她毛衣的一部分，而且他在她的桌面上看到了一个“亲爱的迈克尔”文件夹，他复制了它。他拿到了。帕姆说，你不能读那个，但我可以读。对。帕姆可以读。我不会告诉你具体内容是什么，但我可以告诉你她是否还喜欢你。
We had a lot of fan mail about that.
Emma S, Eric M and Zachary C all wanted to know, was there a letter?
or was I just pretending to read something?
There was a letter.
I wondered that too.
Phil Shea wrote a letter and I was very grateful
because as I read it, it helped me get in a headspace
because there were all these things I read
我们收到了很多关于此事的粉丝邮件。艾玛·S、埃里克·M和扎卡里·C都想知道，真的有一封信吗？还是我只是假装在读什么东西？有一封信。我也想知道。菲尔·谢写了一封信，我非常感激，因为当我读它时，它帮助我进入了一种心态，因为我读到了所有这些东西
but then I knew I was going to tell Michael the scripted lines
of like, it's not over.
And it was great.
It was so helpful as an actor to have not just a blank screen there.
So thank you, Phil Shea, for writing.
me a letter. I wonder if Phil had to consult the writing staff and say, guys, I'm going to write
this letter. Do you have any, or he just did that on his own? I think that was stuff he just did
on his own. He was a very detail-oriented prop master. Yes, and he would often do that if we had
但我知道我要告诉迈克尔那些剧本里的台词，比如“还没结束”。这太棒了。作为一名演员，不仅仅有一个空白屏幕在那里，这非常有帮助。所以谢谢你，菲尔·谢，为我写了一封信。我想知道菲尔是否必须咨询编剧组并说：“伙计们，我要写这封信。你们有什么建议吗？”还是他只是自己做了？我想那是他自己做的事情。他是一个非常注重细节的道具师。是的，如果我们需要
a faky piece of paper. A memo. It was very detailed. Mm-hmm. I have a question for you,
because when I watch this, I am always, like, relating it back to, like, things happening.
would you have read it if you saw like something on your ex's computer, would you have read it?
Yeah. Me too. Of course.
100%. Yeah. I would have just sat down right then and there and read it.
Correct. Okay. I feel better now. Yeah. Well, listen, Michael is thrilled to find out that it's not over with Holly.
And we're not sure yet what he's going to do with that information, but he's happy to know it.
He feels like he has closure.
一张假纸。一份备忘录。它非常详细。嗯哼。我有一个问题要问你，因为当我看到这个时，我总是把它和发生的事情联系起来。如果你在你的前任电脑上看到类似的东西，你会读吗？会。我也是。当然。100%。是的。我会就在那时坐下来读它。没错。好的。我现在感觉好多了。是的。好吧，听着，迈克尔很高兴发现他和霍莉之间还没结束。我们还不确定他会用这些信息做什么，但他很高兴知道这一点。他觉得他有了了结。
Yeah, he does.
We haven't talked about the rest of this birthday storyline.
Well, listen, they're not doing very well.
Jim and Dwight are still trying to brainstorm the perfect party for Kelly.
Yeah.
They're in the conference room.
Jim says, okay, so far, our ideal party consists of beer, fights to the death, cupcakes, blood pudding, blood, touch football, mating, charades,
And yes, horse hunting.
是的，他有了。我们还没谈到这个生日剧情的其余部分。好吧，听着，他们做得不太好。吉姆和德怀特仍在努力为凯莉构思完美的派对。是的。他们在会议室。吉姆说：“好吧，到目前为止，我们理想的派对包括啤酒、死斗、纸杯蛋糕、血布丁、血、触式橄榄球、交配、猜谜游戏，还有，是的，猎马。”
Yeah.
And Dwight's like, you're right.
Forget horse hunting.
It's stupid.
Just only lose that one.
All the rest are viable.
Yeah.
All the rest sound great.
是的。德怀特说：“你说得对。忘了猎马吧。太蠢了。只去掉那一个。其余的都是可行的。”是的。其余的听起来都很棒。
But ultimately, they actually find a theme.
Mm-hmm.
Everyone gathers in the conference room.
Kelly comes in.
There's a cake.
Her name is spelled wrong.
Mm-hmm.
And there's a chicklet.
但最终，他们确实找到了一个主题。嗯哼。每个人都聚集在会议室。凯莉进来了。有一个蛋糕。她的名字拼错了。嗯哼。还有一个“奇克莱特”。
You know what a chicklet is?
I do.
It's a piece of gum and it's a square.
It's a little square piece of gum.
I love a chicklet.
I love a chicklet too.
I like it that has like a candy coating before I chew the gum.
I like the crunch.
你知道什么是“奇克莱特”吗？我知道。那是一块口香糖，它是方形的。它是一小块方形口香糖。我喜欢“奇克莱特”。我也喜欢“奇克莱特”。我喜欢它在嚼口香糖之前有一层糖衣。我喜欢那种脆脆的感觉。
Me too.
Kelly wants to know what's up with the chicklet.
Jim says that's the best part.
The chicklet represents a pillow.
It's a pillow or a television.
That's our theme.
A pillow or a television is their theme.
She gets to decide one hour of TV or an hour of napping.
我也是。凯莉想知道“奇克莱特”是怎么回事。吉姆说那是最好的部分。奇克莱特代表一个枕头。这是一个枕头或一台电视。这就是我们的主题。枕头或电视是他们的主题。她可以决定看一小时电视或睡一小时午觉。
What would you pick?
I would, oh, I don't know if I could sleep at work.
I can't nap in general.
I have to be sick in order to take a nap.
Even if I've gotten three hours of sleep the night before, I can't nap.
I get like wired tired.
So, I mean, I'm in the middle of the White Lotus.
I'm in the middle of hacks.
你会选什么？我会，哦，我不知道我是否能在工作时睡觉。我通常不能午睡。我必须生病才能午睡。即使我前一天晚上只睡了三个小时，我也不能午睡。我变得很兴奋但很累。所以，我的意思是，我正在看《白莲花度假村》。我正在看《绝望写手》。
I only just finished mayor of Easttown.
Do you hear how behind I am?
Yeah.
So hour of TV, yes, please.
That sounds decadent to me.
Also, yeah, I can't sleep during the day.
Something has to be wrong with me if I fall asleep during the day.
It's just like my body just won't do it.
我才刚刚看完《东城梦魇》。你听到我落后了多少吗？是的。所以一小时电视，是的，请。那对我来说听起来很奢侈。而且，是的，我白天睡不着。如果我白天睡着了，我一定是有什么问题。这就像我的身体就是做不到。
I do think this is a little bit of an old tech alert.
What's the old tech?
They say that the chicklet represents a pillow or a television.
And I think it works now.
We would just watch an hour on our phone or our computer.
That's true.
And also, doesn't Stanley say there's nothing good on right now?
Well, Creed says Bonnie Hunt's on.
我觉得这有点像旧技术警报。什么是旧技术？他们说那个小方块代表枕头或电视。我觉得现在也适用。我们只是在手机或电脑上看一小时节目。确实。而且，斯坦利不是说现在没什么好看的吗？嗯，克里德说邦妮·亨特的节目正在播出。
But it's that they're going to watch like live television.
That's right.
Appointment television.
No streaming.
Mm-mm.
So I would say their theme was a little bit of an old tech alert.
I agree.
Well, Kelly chooses nap.
但他们要看的是直播电视。没错。准时收看的电视节目。没有流媒体。嗯嗯。所以我认为他们的主题有点像旧技术警报。我同意。好吧，凯利选择了小睡。
And she takes a little nap under the conference table.
And while she does, Jim and Dwight sit on that little couch by reception and they eat their cake and they're very proud of themselves.
And I want to point out this scene to everyone because John is doing a classic faky, eaty, acting technique with this cake.
He's shoving the food around the plate.
He would take a big scoop of cake, but then he smushes it back down.
And so by the time he puts it in his mouth, it just has a little frosting on it.
Watch it.
He goes for the cake three times and never actually eats a piece.
她在会议桌下小睡了一会儿。当她睡觉时，吉姆和德怀特坐在接待处旁边的小沙发上吃蛋糕，他们对自己感到非常自豪。我想向大家指出这个场景，因为约翰在吃蛋糕时用了一种经典的假吃表演技巧。他把食物在盘子里推来推去。他会舀一大勺蛋糕，但随后又把它压下去。所以当他把它放进嘴里时，上面只有一点糖霜。看着他。他三次去吃蛋糕，但实际上从来没有吃下一块。
At the beginning, he eats like half a piece.
You have to do this because otherwise you're going to get sick.
However, sitting next to him is Rain Wilson who eats the cake.
Because Rain always ate in scenes.
It didn't matter.
Remember he ate so many bananas he got sick.
Yeah.
When Rain as Dwight does anything, he goes all out.
一开始，他吃了一半。你必须这样做，否则你会吃坏肚子。然而，坐在他旁边的是雷恩·威尔逊，他真的吃了蛋糕。因为雷恩在场景里总是吃东西。没关系。记得他吃了那么多香蕉以至于生病了吗？是的。当雷恩饰演的德怀特做任何事情时，他都会全力以赴。
Yep.
And I feel like Rain eats in scenes the way Brad Pitt eats in movies.
Watch an Ocean's 12.
The guy is always eating.
I wanted to know, like, is this a choice?
You're constantly eating something.
Watch Goodfellas.
Do you see how much steak and pasta those guys eat?
是的。我觉得雷恩在场景里吃东西的方式就像布拉德·皮特在电影里吃东西一样。看看《十一罗汉2》。这家伙总是在吃。我想知道，这是一种选择吗？你一直在吃东西。看看《好家伙》。你看到那些家伙吃了多少牛排和意大利面了吗？
They dig in.
Goodfellas makes me hungry.
Yeah.
When I watch it, I get hungry.
For sure.
Guys, guess what?
That was Lecture Circuit Part 2.
Mm-hmm.
他们大快朵颐。《好家伙》让我很饿。是的。当我看它的时候，我就会饿。肯定的。伙计们，猜猜怎么着？那是《讲座巡回》第二部分。嗯嗯。
With a little bit of movie.
Extra stuff.
We had, I felt like, a lot of interesting movie magic facts.
A lot of cat,
grooming facts and a Forrest Gump impression.
Not a bad day.
Not too shabby.
还有一点电影花絮。额外的内容。额外的内容。我觉得我们有很多有趣的电影魔术事实。很多关于猫梳理毛发的事实，还有一个《阿甘正传》的模仿秀。不错的一天。还算不错。
And next week is Blood Drive.
Oh, yeah.
I've got some good facts about the Blood Mobile.
It was actually on the set.
It was in the parking lot, a real one.
Yep.
I'll tell you all about it next week.
下周是《献血活动》。哦，是的。我有一些关于献血车的有趣事实。它实际上就在片场。它就在停车场里，是一辆真正的献血车。是的。是的。下周我会告诉你们所有关于它的事情。
See you next week.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink.
This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf.
Office Ladies is a presentation of
Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
Our second drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill
Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton.
下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的第二杯剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。